Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
We're okay.
Oh, o, o, oh, o, o, o, Okizen-sama.
Hello.
Hi.
I'm Mir consultation.
Hello.
Okairi!
What's so funny?
I did this.
You hear it?
You like that?
I like the double audio?
Kinda sounds cool now, actually.
Wait, you guys don't hear the double audio?
Congrats on 200k!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
No?
The whole time you've heard the single audio?
That's so weird.
Don't hear it double.
Definitely double.
Yeah, it was double for a second.
I heard it at the start.
Okay, I feel like I'm going crazy.
You guys like the new emo?
It's...
Excuse me, waiter.
This ghost is too tricky.
Busting.
Do you like them?
They're so fun.
Thank you, Tuna.
Thank you, Walfi.
Where the new ones?
This is not all of them.
There will be more.
Sai, welcome to the membership.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
The ring taco.
Thank you for the birthday gift.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Amy, thank you for the gift.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
More?
Yeah, I'm gonna get more.
I have, um...
I don't remember how many more slots I have.
But I have more.
Hmm.
I have to get the...
Get them commissioned.
Fun!
Thank you for the 10!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifting.
Thank you so much.
Um... All the slots for sure.
I think so.
I don't know...
I don't remember how many it is exactly but um earlier
actually just a half hour ago I got off um with a finishing
recording with Mataro the next podcast episode and we had
talked like for two hours before that so I'm a little sleepy
Kieran welcome to membership there and go um you what I did
the podcast.
Oh, hey, y'all.
And, um, no, I don't want to do a short stream because I
want to get through this.
I've been having fun playing it.
but, uh, and then before that, this morning, I had a
meeting.
So, it's been a busy day for me.
I've just been, I've just been in my, I'm on my computer the
whole time.
So...
Yeah.
But I'm excited to play Ghost Trick.
So, um, the reason I say all that is because if my voice...
If my... if my voice...
starts to get weird, it's because I've been talking all day.
Stampu Fueita.
So!
New stampu Dekita.
Yeah.
What did you have a meeting about?
I can't say.
Oh my gosh.
And yesterday I went to the doctor's office.
And it was so sad.
I hate going to the...
Nothing bad happened.
I just hate going to the doctor's office.
So, yeah.
Let's...
Wow.
This doctor...
Thank you.
Wait, oh, hold on.
Did you see that Konami is bringing back the Metal Gear
Solid Ducks?
Specifically, Ocelot, Arrakon, and Psychomantis.
Have fun tricking ghosts.
Thanks!
I did see that they posted about it.
Wait, so there's no new Solid Snake?
I think I want the Ocelot Duck, but I think I'm okay with
the other ones.
I've been waiting for this milestone.
on chat since 2021.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
I only have solid snake.
I hope you are healthy.
I think I am.
What am I going to do?
Die again?
Yeah.
But, uh, how do you do the...
How do you do the...
The emote with the little...
With the...
With the wind.
I wanted to do it with the clown.
Looks like he was passing a little gas.
4 a.m.
can't sleep.
We're going to watch Pinto.
I hope that I can help you sleep a little bit more.
Oh, is it Dash?
Quack, sir.
Yeah, it's like the...
Fart unleashed.
Oh my gosh.
Stop it, you guys.
Stop it.
Okay.
So last time on Ghost Trick, we...
We found out that we are dead.
And we have special ghost powers where we can possess any
inanimate thing.
We're trying to figure out who killed us.
us we also have special powers where we can go back in time
and save people from becoming dead because we saved a dog
and a lady what you're dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead yeah
we saved missile the best dog ever we saved a lady we don't
know her yet and there were some blue guys i love missile i
love missile
Dad?
Dad.
Let's continue.
What's on the extras?
I think this is like all the background.
Wait, challenges?
Oh, wait.
Cleared ghost trick.
75% of what?
I've already cleared 75% of something.
History of a secret.
Wait, maybe I...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh.
Uh-oh!
Don't look at that!
And we have illustrations.
Oh, look at that!
This is such a good wallpaper for...
Oh, I can zoom in and out.
For my streams.
Oh my gosh, this is the one I use for my streams.
Oh, the junkyard!
That's one of the guys.
Tippy toes?
I don't remember his name.
There's a girl sick in this bed.
LAMP Near-sighted Jigo Down, thanks for the 20 gift And
thank you!
Thank you so much Alright, let's get started though
Wee-pee-pee-pee-pee-pee-pee-pee-pee We started At Well,
they're both the same Let's go, oh, someone else just died
We have to save the girl again Don't we?
Well, I don't know, what was her name Emily
Okay Oh gosh Okay We're tricking again We can swivel the
desk Okay Now we're going ghost again And we're Oh we can
examine the notebook What's up with this blinding pink
notebook Lynn Lynn that was her shot Oh no I'm sorry Her
name.
Her name was Loon.
I read shot.
Somebody stuck it behind the bookcase at a haphazard angle.
Maybe that's the superintendent's way of tidying up.
Her shot.
Sorry.
Oh.
Oh, we can turn on the lamp.
We're showing them the notebook.
There's also the book up here that we can't get up to yet.
Ew, what are these?
There's like a whole contraption down here.
Interesting, interesting.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there we go.
She's probably still sleepy.
Matroshka.
Unconscious this time as well, eh?
That was the audio, by the way.
Oh!
She's awake!
Where am I?
Oh my gosh, she's awake!
She's awake!
She's coming, too?
You're gonna extract him, too?
What happened to me?
Audio's good?
Oh, God.
Excuse me.
ignoring me?
Oh, sorry.
I'm still not used to talking with dead people, you see.
Dead?
It's in red.
So I'm dead, huh?
Hmm.
Try as I might, I can't seem to remember who I am.
She's starting to remind me of me.
Who am I?
Everybody seems to call you Lynn, if that's any help.
Lynn, huh?
pretty cute name and apparently you're a detective too
detective you mean that super cool kind of cop that solves
crimes and upholds justice sounds like a pretty subjective
description but yes that kind of detective quote-unquote I
love that this game has two buttons ghost and trick um wait
a minute um I Actually, are you starting to remember
something?
Oh my god!
Mike Tyson's ass!
Thanks for the five, Katya!
Thank you!
We umi-neko now.
Oh.
Is my chair okay?
There's no time to lose!
Something really unusual is going down in this town tonight.
What?
Ray Mack, thanks for the five, Katya!
Yeah, I certainly won't argue with the really unusual part.
His song is so fun.
That's not your face, you know.
Take another look.
You're the dead one.
Oh, right, of course.
It'd be pretty heinous if I looked like this, I guess,
wouldn't it?
I don't know if heinous is the right word.
Wow, the stuck things are the five gifted!
There we go!
She was just, she was actually stealing that guy's identity.
Something really unusual is going on in this town tonight.
Could I have anything to do with my death, I wonder.
This is my 7 a.m.
alarm.
You wake up to this?
Oh gosh, this is triggering for you then probably.
Identity theft is not a joke.
Sorry, sorry, I didn't mean to.
I'm just going to put my...
Remember that guy that put his social security on, like, a
truck and drove it around New York?
And then said, no one will steal my identity.
It's protected by this company.
And then it all got stolen.
Don't ever tell people.
Don't ever challenge people, you know?
What is going on in this town tonight?
Don't ask me.
I'm dead.
I don't remember anything.
I can't remember her thing.
I think it's probably because I'm dead.
Everything is so confusing!
Can't you do something?
Oh, wait.
If he protects her or brings her back, will she be able to
remember who we are just like Missal, the dog?
Hey, you're asking the wrong guy.
Same for you, Mint.
What do you mean?
That I have no memories or don't challenge me?
But I've got some things to ask you about.
Oh.
She's not gonna remember me though.
What about her death?
So I died, huh?
Yes, apparently.
I'm very sorry.
How could this have happened?
And after I just passed my test, finally, this- wait, she
remembers!
My exciting career of catching the bad guys has just begun.
And now look at me!
Why did I have to go and die in an old junkyard like this?
Poor shock.
Oh, wait.
Poor kid.
The shock is setting in.
Poor shock.
And so I told her everything that happened tonight about
ghost tricks, possessing, and manipulating objects, minutes
before a person's death.
Poor shock.
This actually isn't the first time you died tonight, you
know.
That's so freaky.
Oh my gosh, can you imagine?
You were already shot and killed once before tonight.
And you saved me?
That's right.
You don't remember?
Flashback.
Oh, death.
Slip.
Let's get rid of the funky music.
Death isn't that funny, you guys.
Yes, I think I do remember something like that happening.
Vaguely.
Yes, I did get shot by a blue man dressed in all black.
How does she remember that?
I guess that means that even if a death is erased, the
memory of it remains.
Oh my gosh, you can remember how it hurt and everything?
The pain.
So I died twice already tonight.
Unlucky.
Is Mint literate?
Um.
Wish I knew what to say to her.
Guess I'll just have to wait until she recovers a little.
Hey, I bet that's some kind of a record, don't you think?
Yeah, you're probably right.
Looks like she's pretty much recovered already.
About me.
Do you remember anything about me?
I'm looking for the answers to the questions.
Who am I?
And, uh, why was I killed?
Do you know anything that might help me?
She can't read chat.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I'm also gonna be yawning tonight.
The only thing I know right now is that my name is Cicil.
Your name is Cicil, huh?
I think so.
It rings some kind of a bell anyway.
I think I was killed tonight while I was meeting with you.
at least know me, I think.
I was meeting with you?
Yes, in the junkyard outside.
I'm Eepy.
I have a...
Sorry, also.
I'm sorry if I'm so grumpy.
I don't think I'll be grumpy.
But I haven't been able to sleep much the past couple nights
because of the... What's the word?
The pinched nerve in my neck keeps me out.
sorry if i'm grumpy
grumpy i'm grumpy mince illiterate she can read the fine
print on solid snakes but it's not it's not fine print i
mean his i mean that's that's not what's fine about it
but yeah i'm sorry if i'm i'm trying to sleep I can't
because I'm I'm I don't know I like just I twist and turn
and it's all pain anyway it's coming back to me I remember
now I knew it I knew you were the lead I needed but I'm so
sorry I don't think I can help you she says with a smile but
why not cuz I don't know you what do you mean I thought you
said you remembered me oh she only saw us dead i knew it
said i remembered something i remember the fact that i don't
oh i don't know you no way
two strangers so you don't know me huh nope wish i did so do
you suppose we're just two strangers who happened to me
tonight no way i don't think it was any accident Our lead,
man.
Why in the world would I be way out here in the middle of
nowhere for no reason?
I was asked to come here tonight.
Asked to come.
By who?
Your yawn is making me yawn.
I'm sorry.
If I have to get some coffee later, I will.
If I have to have to have...
I'm having tea right now, but if I have to have coffee,
that's okay too.
Can't you kind of guess where this is going?
We were set up.
Oh, you're kidding me?
Bingo.
By you.
Oh.
I asked you to come here?
But why?
Oh.
That's not what I was getting at.
Oh my god.
Good thing she's the detective.
That's why I was going to ask you.
Oh, that's what I was going to ask you.
Why did you ask me to come here tonight?
Way out here in the middle of nowhere.
Oh my god, a love confession.
You gotta be kidding me.
It goes without saying that I don't remember.
Everything is so confusing.
Can't you do something?
Lynn.
I'm not saying you owe me or anything.
But I have a favor to ask.
What is it?
In the next four minutes...
I didn't make a sound.
The next four minutes you'll probably come back to life.
When you do, do you think you could try to find...
Wait, do you think you could try to find out about me before
tomorrow morning?
Yeah, and I'm sleepy, who I am, and why I was killed.
Do you guys know a way to stop yawning?
Like, legitimately.
I used to have a job where I would wake up at, like, 4 a.m.
And I was teaching English, and I would, like, have to,
like, I would be on...
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Anonymous, thanks for the vibe, gifted.
Thank you.
um i would like i don't think you can right i don't think so
i either almost dropped my controller but i i would be so
tired in the morning and then they would like they would
they would they would um they would say they would get on my
classroom and they would tell me to stop yawning or i would
like pause my screen so that they wouldn't see that was
yawning and they'd be like stop pausing your screen i was
like i'm yawning and they're like, no, it's, it's, it's
rude.
Don't yawn.
I was like, I'm sorry.
Take deeper breaths.
Won't that make you sleepy, though?
I know that they don't want me to yawn so that other people
won't yawn.
How am I supposed to stop myself to yawn?
Ah, man.
I still yawn.
I'm really sorry.
But I can't make it.
any promises.
Might as well tell you to stop sneezing.
Right?
Why not?
They're the people I taught.
Okay.
Who knows?
Why not?
I don't remember very clearly right now.
But I think I was investigating a case tonight.
A case that is very, very important to me.
So even if I come back to life, I don't think I'll have time
to find out anything about you.
You
I know that's a terrible thing to say to the person who
saved my life once already.
Apparently cold drinks and cold snacks.
I have a warm drink.
Uh-oh.
I'm messing it up.
I'm really, really sorry.
Let's see.
That's too bad.
But I'm afraid I'm still going to ask you.
Ask me what?
Ask you to save me.
Even though I probably won't be able to help you.
I know it's selfish of me.
I really apologize.
But I just can't die.
Not yet.
Not like this.
It's alright, Mint.
Don't worry about it.
I'm investigating something important tonight.
I think maybe that might be the reason I was killed.
But I still want to solve that case in spite of all of that.
Am I out of line?
Didn't I tell you a minute ago?
you don't owe me.
I'm certainly not gonna treat your life like some kind of
bargaining chip.
I'll save you.
What you do after that is up to you.
He's so awesome.
He's so cool.
Shesso!
You ready to go back?
Back to four minutes before you got shot?
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Yeah, rewind time!
Okay, four minutes before death.
We gotta see what's going on.
Okay.
Lynn's second death.
I'm heading back in time now to rewind, rewrite her fight.
Faced with those circumstances, she could have just lied and
promised to help me.
But she didn't.
That's when I knew I could trust her.
So much sleepy.
I'm going to, after this I'm going to get, I'm going to get
coffee.
Don't worry.
Okay, here we go.
We're watching her.
She's on the phone.
I have a bad feeling about this.
Yes!
Oh!
Is this the guy that shot her?
Detective!
Is everything okay?
Oh!
I was hungry!
So I was trying to get something delivered.
What?
Don't do that?
Oh, I'm...
I'm sorry.
You should leave jobs like that to me.
Is chicken all right?
He's so cute.
One chicken dinner.
Winner, winner.
What a nice guy.
Oh, that's okay.
I'm not feeling very hungry anymore.
Where was he gonna order from?
I would like to go back to the station for a minute though
you would oh i'm afraid i can't let you do that i wish mint
would teach me english what do you want to learn what do you
want to know minty do you know about the new auto generated
chat summary that youtube implemented seeing it pop up in
your stream is decently accurate i have wait if we keep
saying chicken will it start saying like the chat is talking
about chicken dinner and that That they'll be winners for
eating it.
I never see them.
I never see the...
I only see the ones that people like screenshot and then
post on Twitter later.
But I don't see it myself.
Winner winner, chicken dinner.
Chicken dinner, chicken dinner, chicken dinner, chicken
dinner.
It might be mobile only.
I think so.
Did someone say chicken?
Why can't you let me go back to the station?
Inspector Cabanela is on his way.
He'll be here any minute.
Oh, there he is.
Wow!
Evening, patrol man.
Sir, good evening, Inspector Cabanela, sir.
Chickens are the new melons.
chickens nice work now do me a favor and take a little
patrol around outside would you this guy killed me no way
but it came in through the window that's a nice fellow yes I
love this little officer guy he's so cute yo how's it going
baby inspector Cabanela what are you doing here imagine him
with an Elvis I am I'm doing Elvis voice.
Is it not good?
Wait, I am doing an Elvis voice.
Is it not?
Or is it not a good Elvis voice?
You hear it?
Six out of ten?
It's either Elvis or Johnny, bro.
I thought this special um, oh, oh, oh, daft elf.
Thank you for the five-gifted.
Thank you so much.
I thought this investigation unit had an important
top-secret assignment tonight what does that matter at a
time like this when my Lin's in crisis my Lin my Lin's in
crisis I appreciate it sir who are you you my in oh yeah
wait a minute did you Did you just say crisis?
Don't tell me I'm being suspected?
Uh-oh.
Suspected of shooting that pointy-haired man in the red
suit?
I mean, I've never even met the guy before!
Oh.
Hmm.
Never, baby.
Oh, well, uh...
Uh-oh.
Before tonight, I mean, he asked me to meet him here.
Hmm...
He said he had important information about the big case I'm
working on.
He's the one who contacted me!
I see, I see.
But it's funny, isn't it?
I took a look at the list of cases your station is handling
right now.
And I didn't see you listed as involved on any big cases.
We're rogue!
She's rogue!
You can't stop me, Dad.
You're not my dad.
You might be my dad.
But my dad wouldn't call me baby.
You know I don't suspect you, baby.
I'm just trying to clear things up.
Hubba, hubba.
Wait, what does Elvis say?
Humana, humana.
Wait, what?
Who, yeah.
Wait, what is...
It just says baby.
Hubba, hubba.
Oh, hubba.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're not the type to ever shoot anybody.
Hey, who knows you're better than me, baby?
You know, if anything ever happened to you, I'd kill
everyone in this room and then myself.
I'd never be able to look him in the eye again.
My dad?
Inspector Cabanella, I'm going to ask you a question.
Yeah?
And what's that?
Oh my god, she's gonna get shot before she can ask.
And I want you to answer honestly.
Don't delay.
You're about to get hit.
Is it tonight?
Oh, is that when it's happening?
Honka, honka!
I have no idea what you're talking about, baby.
Get down!
Oh!
That's that.
It seems to me that baby is indeed under suspicion.
By Inspector Cabanella?
No, he's not like that.
Just for the record.
Did you shoot me?
Me?
I would never do anything like that.
Anyway, it looks like the hitman fired from outside.
It'd be hard to prevent the bullet from coming in, though.
Hmm...
In any case, let's just give it a try.
Our four-minute game.
Our four-minute 12-hour game.
Hmm.
Trick time.
You know what?
I have an idea.
The guy who shot me is outside, right?
Looks that way, yeah?
Instead of trying to stop the bullet once it gets in here,
wouldn't it be more fun to go out and stop the guy who's
shooting the bullet?
like it fun she says with eyes gleaming oh boy you can use
the telephone to move around right that's right and i know
the telephone number to the junkyard payphone too but we're
upstairs and the shot i don't want to get shot again you
know what they say about three strikes and you're out as
long as you don't become a ball player you'll probably be
safe but the telephone thing's a good idea maybe I'll give
it a try what she's saying here I have a bad feeling about
this yes I don't remember wait detective is everything okay
oh okay this is just to restart it my bad let me let me turn
ghost let me turn ghost turn ghost ghost trick oh ghost okay
let's see where can we go to the motor okay step ladder whoa
okay let's see what this is microscope photos what's in the
photos these pictures are old what are they of little
fragments of rock we're going ghost And the fragments are
glowing.
Do you know what these are?
It's, um, nuclear.
Radioactive.
Sorry, but I've lost my memory.
Probably not the best person to ask.
That's okay.
I was only being polite.
I didn't really think you'd know.
Ouch.
This lady's tongue can be sharp.
I can hear what you're...
She can hear what we're thinking?
I know.
Good one.
No way!
She can hear what we're thinking?
No!
That's so scary.
What could this be?
It looks like a giant nail clipper.
You think so?
Do you know what it is?
Why did you have to ask me?
Couldn't you see I was looking away evasively?
It's one of those sciencey things that scientists use.
Ordinary people like us don't have to know what it is.
You're a detective, you need to know everything!
I don't remember what science is.
Mom, where does science come from?
But it's apparently something Lynn doesn't like very much.
She doesn't like or doesn't know.
Wee!
Okay, uh...
Do we know what's in the notebook?
because this seems kind of important.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's mine.
Isn't it adorable?
Yee-yee-ye.
Cicel skipped first grade.
Why isn't your adorable notebook in your pocket?
I panicked, okay?
Don't you shove things in the bookcase when you panic?
Who are you calling anyway?
It was personal business.
I don't like the sound of that, Missy.
Oh, we still can't go with that.
threw anything down here.
Oh, I was gonna say, can I even get to the telephone?
Alright, let's try dialing it.
Micmac!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Oh, that's funny.
What's the matter?
This telephone doesn't seem to be working right now.
Usually the telephone line glows red, but it's dark right
now.
Oh, isn't it in the four minutes we can't use it?
Apparently.
Yeah, in this four minutes before death, we can't use the
phone lines.
Yes, yes, yes.
I remember now.
As long as the lines are closed like this, it looks like we
can't go anywhere.
But I want to stop that criminal!
Hmm.
Where else can we go?
Notebook.
There's a lot of stuff going on down here.
Oh, yeah.
I'm a little bald.
Can I move?
No.
We can't get that book either, still.
what do you mean let's see if if i swivel it if he does
anything this guy is unfazed he's like i've seen worse uh i
know this ain't my first poltergeist i don't have anything
else over here really so there's not really a reason to go
over here oh wait i said i did it earlier though i wanted to
turn the lamp on so that they would look at the notebook.
Huh?
That's Lynn's notebook.
Hey, wait a minute.
I did this earlier.
La la la la la la.
I thought she was practicing a dance move when I came.
Nope.
That was definitely suspicious.
No question.
I'd better report this.
I wonder if I can make the call without her noticing.
you little snitch you little snitch huh what's
up I've been watching Lynn just like you told me to and I
noticed something suspicious sus when the notebook is sus oh
you did some of that Spector Cabanilla was right.
She was hiding her notebook when I came in.
Her notebook, eh?
Yes, yes, sir.
In a very suspicious manner.
And in a very conspicuous place.
Just throwing all the memes out there.
Okay, but when you think of Among Us, do you not think of
Five Nights at Freddy's, too?
Anything else?
Let's see.
It's pink.
And it's a notebook!
You don't?
Anything else?
Um, let's see.
Come to think of it.
She was using the phone when I came in too.
And referring to her notebook!
Why would I?
I don't know.
What's the connection?
Um, beloved by children.
Okay, someone will be over later.
Don't let on you noticed anything.
Okay.
Look at that!
The phone line is glowing red!
I bet it would work if we tried it now.
I bet you're right.
The detective he's talking to is outside in the junkyard.
I mean, FNAF also has vents.
So true!
So true.
And that's where the horrible hitman who's after me is too.
I guess so.
Go to there.
Okay.
The most, the most ominous lamp I've ever...
What?
The Notebook starring acclaimed actor Ryan Gosling?
He's not in that.
Is he?
I've been waiting for you.
Yeek!
What are you?
A test clamp.
That sounds like an... Oh, like an old grandpa.
Sounds like an old grandpa.
Just call me Ray.
Grandpa Ray.
You just have to get the grandpa part in there somewhere,
don't you?
Well, we didn't have that context before.
Interesting.
We're souls.
We can choose any appearance we like.
Which means you have no intention of showing us what you
really look like, right?
Now then.
About that gunshot that took you alive.
So Mint could also turn into a lamp?
I mean, I guess if I wanted to...
Do you want me to turn into a lamp?
Do you want me to turn into like anamorphs into a lamp?
The notebook with Ryan Gosling.
No, it's not I'm looking this up if it's the really Ryan
Gosling in the notebook I'll eat my shoe
No, it's not Ryan
Gosling.
Oh my god
No way!
Wait, who is Nicholas Sparks then?
Who is, wait.
That shoe tastes good.
Don't use the cloud emoji.
No way!
The author of the book the movie is based on...
No, no way.
I thought you guys were kidding.
I thought you were kidding because of the Ryan Gosling meme.
But he doesn't have a beard.
Time for lunch.
Okay, I'll eat it.
I'll eat it at the end of stream, okay?
Let me get through the stream first.
I heard I hear shoes taste just like tree frogs Stop the
clown emoji I heard it Way up on the upper level A scant few
minutes from now The hitman is probably getting his rifle
ready Right now Alright I'm going in I'll get in with those
ghosties trick thingies I'm very sorry young lady but how
does it taste no that's okay meant surely right surely Ryan
Gosling isn't his real name
you don't have those powers no sir what why not I'm afraid I
don't know the reason but only a special few have the powers
of the dead what are you saying i'm not special that's not
fair i got a trophy for participating in the game when i was
a kid i'm special anyway we don't have much time
come on and hop in oh he's greeting us to enter his body
there he goes he's gonna go upstairs carry on boys
Fate changed.
Um.
Okay.
We're going crazy.
Uh.
If I fold this here.
Can we go up?
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, it's this part again.
Refrigerator.
Oh.
There's nothing.
Nothing near.
Your shoes are chocolate, though, right?
Yeah.
Thought bubble above.
It's okay.
I don't want...
I don't want the hints.
Oh, there he goes!
Oh my gosh, he's on the stairs!
It's so crazy.
But we gotta hop inside the lamp.
Ray.
Trick.
Oh.
What do you mean by hop in, then?
What do you mean by that?
Let's see, what other things can we perform tricks on?
We can ghost trick me.
Maybe we do this part again.
Oh, time is passing!
Oh, wait.
This needs to be on, right?
Oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
Ha ha!
Why are you taking the bike?
No, no, no!
Okay, we saw him take the bike.
There he goes.
We should get going ourselves.
It feels like we lost, you know?
If there's one thing I hate, it's losing a race.
I wasn't aware we were in a race with the inspector.
Think barber pulls stripes.
You're red and he is white.
And it's a race to the top.
indulge her and try again.
Yeah, let's try this again.
Oh, I cleared... I cleared a song?
Wait, what's going on?
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Turn...
On.
There's nothing else we could do here.
Maybe we were supposed to turn it on or turn it off when he
was up here.
Fun's for a good barbecue sauce to go with the leathery
taste of...
Thanks.
Yeah, I think we missed the bike.
Oh, but we see who's the guy.
Oh my gosh.
We see the guy, though.
Look, there he is, way up there.
The horrible hitman.
I think his name is actually Tengu, but I guess that doesn't
matter.
Let's go grind him to pieces.
I wish he wouldn't use such violent expressions.
Besides, I don't see any cores that will get us over there.
I think we might have missed our chance already.
Timing is everything.
Okay, sir.
Uh.
Oh.
Um.
Okay, let's do it after the fate change.
Okay.
He's always one step ahead.
I know!
That's okay.
We don't need to...
We know that she's gonna die.
We know how to get up there.
And foe!
Squared word, tortellini!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Alright.
I know I'm just gonna...
What is this?
What did they say anyway?
That horrible hitman that's after me is upstairs, isn't he?
Apparently.
In other words, we can't stop him if we stay down here.
See?
I didn't need the hint, you guys.
I was going... I was already on my way up there.
I was already on my way up there.
Now we wait.
It's time to hunt down that horrible hitman.
He must be around here somewhere preparing to take his shot.
One step ahead, Minto.
Let's try to find him fast.
I'm going to make...
I'm going to make good and sure he understands what happens
to people who point guns at others.
There's a gleam.
So, what if maybe...
The spotlight highlights him, maybe?
This is what we might have to do.
Time is passing.
He might, like, kick it if he gets so...
scared.
Uh...
What did I do wrong?
Okay.
I'm going ghost!
What did I do wrong?
There's nothing else we can do.
What if I roll the tire?
Might have been a dumb idea.
Okay, yeah, there's nothing over here.
Okay.
Can you jump to his bike?
Oh!
What are you talking?
Oh my gosh.
He's dancing his way.
Go, go, go!
I thought that I was going to startle him with the light.
You guys...
It's...
I just...
Oh yeah, because I see now the bike.
it's lit up.
Guys, I had a good idea, okay?
Okay.
Here he comes.
Ah!
Close.
Nice.
I'm going ghost.
There he is.
Spotlight him.
Spotlight him!
I see my target.
Time to go to work.
I'll be head of the hitter.
Hitman division by next month now for sure.
There he is!
The horrible Hitman!
Oh, we said this before.
We have to stop him from shooting!
Fast!
Oh!
Uh, open!
Time is passing!
Turn the spotlight on!
Yeah!
Bozo!
We put a stop to that shot at least.
I'm so I'm safe now right well that changed your fate a
little but it didn't avert it completely we're not done yet
the hitman is a professional and he really really wants to
be head of the division apparently I get blinded Bozo this
guy this stupid guy behind us yeah I vouched for you I
vouched for you but you can't even notice a guy hitman
coming from behind the car I doubt blocking a shot here and
there is really gonna stop him we have to kill him we have
to splat him just like the last guy if you want to rough him
up a little bit i promise i won't put it in my report you
made that bet knowing well that ghosts don't wear shoes
what no no that was my oh she's so effigy stop it stop it
Stop it.
Come on.
Stop.
Stop it.
Okay.
I was gonna say something else, but I don't want to go to
the bathroom just yet.
Let's think of something else before he gets a shot in.
Fate has been changed.
We're gonna pedal to the metal with this guy.
Pedal, pedal, pedal.
pedal oh we're stuck here just kidding we're gonna bicycle
close the door
oh come here come here come here night stick oh there we go
there we go there we go we got to get the next spotlight oh
my gosh don't you notice
Oh my god, this guy is so oblivious.
Your hat is too low on your face.
You can't see anything in front of you.
If I want that position, I have to be careful of even the
least bit of light.
Division head is my ambition for this year.
Next year, my motto will be, If I want to be director, I
have to be careful of even the least bit of scandal.
So it sounds like he won't show up in spots where a light is
on.
I heard some nasty scandalous rumors about him.
Wee-woo!
Flashing light!
Oh!
What?
Wait, they didn't see him.
Hey, did you turn that flashing light on?
Wasn't me.
It went off all by itself.
Scared the heck out of me.
Well, just make sure you lay off it.
Don't want to waste any electricity.
Wow, they're so...
They're so conscious.
Have things gotten that tight?
That's pretty sad.
They're really putting the squeeze on us lately about using
too much power at sites.
They won't even let us use all of our search lights at once.
Interesting.
Oh boy.
We ought to be free to do at least that much, especially on
a dark night like tonight.
Uh oh.
I think I need to follow this guy now.
passing.
Oh, maybe I was wrong.
What?
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Budget cuts.
What are you gonna do exactly?
Hey, I told you.
I think if we make it so we can't do the shot from here,
it'll at least keep the spotlight on the other location, you
know?
So he won't be able to go back to the other car, but he also
won't be able to get it here.
That's what I think.
I told you to lay off that thing.
And I told you, it wasn't me.
Uh-oh.
I think I might know what's going on here.
This is the work of...
You know.
What?
Hey, shut up!
You're creeping me out!
But you know as well as I do the only explanation for
mischief like this is...
I'm not gonna get caught here, am I?
Oh, Inspector Cabanella!
So they tell tales about him as though he's a ghost, eh?
Spectre Cavanella is really a very nice person.
Oh, ghost!
Oh, jinkies!
Wait, so if I just stay here...
It doesn't feel like I'm doing so much.
You're allegedly a ghost.
What's the best trick?
I don't know.
What if I do this?
Nothing happens.
That's funny.
I thought this lever was for swinging the crane arm around.
I'd like to swing that horrible hitman around.
This crane.
I wonder if there's some other way we can use it.
Oh, wait.
My bad.
Can we reach the light?
We can.
But if I do this...
I would have to go back with the other guy to get back up to
the crane.
But then that one turns off.
Okay, wait, I think I messed up.
One of the lights went out.
There are three lights here altogether.
Apparently we can't have all three of them on at once.
Our station is crazy cheap when it comes to electricity.
So just another detective could see what he was doing the
other day.
I had to pedal my bicycle in place to work the headlamp.
Oh my god.
Very sad tale indeed.
Sounds like they're taking things way too far.
So I'm going to turn this one off.
I need to get...
Wait, come back!
Uh-oh.
Wait, come back, officer!
Oh my gosh, please.
Please.
Sir.
Time is passing!
Oh my god, I hear him!
I hear him!
Oh my god, please!
Oh my god!
okay okay see
the bike I couldn't pedal can I pedal this one no so let's
wait for our little guy here let's wait for our guy then
we'll do it again at the other side then maybe try something
with the with the with the what the what the oh my Oh
my gosh, why?
Oh my gosh, why?
Oh my god, I'm not gonna make it!
No!
Where is he gonna shoot her from?
Uh, let's see.
Rays here.
Oh, neat.
Okay.
Oh shoot!
Such power and such speed.
I bet that would put a nice stop to my horrible hitman.
Okay how do we move it?
It just stopped and that would be fine.
Phoenix thanks for the membership!
Welcome welcome.
If it killed him would I be obliged to save him?
Anyway let's just focus on the stopping part.
Apparently thinking about things too deeply isn't something
you like to do.
Just the right amount.
That's the way detectives think about things.
How do I move this?
Oh, I just love stamping out evil.
It makes me feel so alive.
Except for the fact that you're dead.
Uh...
The...
Open.
Whee!
Oh!
Oh, what?!
Okay.
Rema- Everybody, if I ask to open the umbrella, don't let me
do it.
Wait, did we see this before?
Wait, I think we can pretty safely assume this was the
murder weapon.
Wait, I think we did.
That pistol.
Same model as the pistol you detected.
Yeah, we saw this before.
You don't think it's Lynn, do you?
This is not good.
We've read all this.
we made it go off.
That's all right.
It's a good recap.
This is the act of somebody who's jealous of my abilities as
a detective.
Sorry if I'm not reading all of it.
I'm just gonna...
Oh.
There it is.
Her death.
Time's up.
Okay.
Have to look for the right time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh no, we have to go all the way from...
Oh my gosh.
That's a long amount of time we have to...
Oh wait!
Oh okay, interesting.
We can't do anything with the pedal.
We only pedaled to get down here.
How do I get up there?
Also see, I think the street lamp can be possessed.
Hmm.
Oh, look, my bad.
Mr. Come back, please.
Thank you, sir.
What else can...
Yeah, the lamp can also be.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
But the lever didn't do anything.
Follow this guy.
I wonder if we do anything on the...
The guitar is still all...
Filled with bullet holes, that's so funny.
Raise!
Okay.
And if I lowered it, it didn't really do anything.
No.
I'm just confused how to get over there.
Oh no!
Wait, I can make it, I can make it!
Oh I can't make it!
I can't!
I can't make it!
Oh no, he's gonna shoot her!
Oh no, please!
Don't shoot!
Come back, sir!
Oh my god, he's loading his gun.
This one!
We need him to show up at this one!
Wait, but this one...
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, wait.
Which one did it turn?
Oh, no, yeah, because we already turned it off.
Okay, now come back, please!
Sir?
So, please come back.
Thank you.
Okay, good thing we turned off that spotlight right there
first.
And then...
Oh, that's where you show up, eh?
Big dummy.
This is quite a distance from the target.
But I can't work under a spotlight after all.
Never mind.
A shot like this is nothing for a man of my skill.
I mean, you're a sniper.
That's what you're supposed to do, distance.
Mr. Division Head seems to like dark, gloomy places.
I'd be happy to throw him in a dark, gloomy cell.
Or into dark, gloomy hell.
Ah, ha, ha, ha.
Oh, when did I become her assistant?
Wait, wait, wait, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No!
What?
Whoa, they talked?
No way!
Okay.
Time is passing.
Just a little bit more.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm going, ghost!
It's over for you, mister.
Oh, my god.
Oh, did you hear a scream just now?
I'm telling you, it wasn't me.
Oh, my gosh, I killed two people tonight.
Dang.
I've killed two people just to save one girl.
And a dog.
I mean, the dog was worth it.
But what if the girl is evil?
There.
We found a nice dark spot for our gloom-loving hitman.
I think your death has been erased.
Again.
Fate averted!
Does Lynn seem evil?
Maybe.
I don't know, I can't, I don't know if I can trust her spiky
hair.
Why not, I wonder?
Huh?
Why don't I have powers like yours?
If I could do things like you do, it could really help me
pursue my case.
Why only this special few, huh?
It's not fair.
That's the same thing the little doggy said, too.
because yeah you get to stay alive you are why because your
life can be saved even if you die again tonight I can save
you with my ghost tricks nobody can save my life though oh
yeah I'm dead lady you should appreciate your life I'm dead
this powers of the dead why have they chosen me will I find
the answer to that question tonight I bet we Well, not in
tonight's stream, maybe, but I don't know.
Cicel, I'm so sorry.
Well, you're free to do as you please now.
I guess this is goodbye, detective.
Will we ever see each other again?
If you ever want to see me again, all you have to do is die.
Okay, got it.
I was kidding.
Well, guess we'd better be getting back to the present.
Kikikik.
Kakui.
Is that really kakui to say die for me?
Lin is cute so she's worth saving.
Lin has escaped death for a second time.
But that doesn't mean she's out of the water yet.
I'd better go see how she's doing.
Can you imagine?
What if you just like...
What if you do the four minutes before death over and over
and over and over again?
and like no matter how many tries you did there was never a
way to save them what if you're put in a situation where
they have to die you know that's kind of dark but like
that's just Steinsgate that's called Steinsgate but in but
in this game my gosh I love Steinsgate I better go see how
she's doing.
I'm going ghost!
Meow.
Oh, whose bag is this?
Mr. Officer, are you coming back?
Oh, wait, who's gonna...
How am I gonna get over there?
Check on how she's doing.
Oh, wait!
I can check with the umbrella.
That's why the umbrella's there.
Through the phone.
Yeah, I already thought of it before you.
Wee!
Was that light on before?
Uh, wait.
Here.
There.
Oh, this way.
Well, it looks like congratulations are in order.
Oh, sorry.
It looks like congratulations are in order.
erased yet another death.
Oh, aren't we so clever?
I know.
But I haven't gotten any further in solving my own mystery,
though.
But that woman holds the key.
Don't forget that.
Lynn, huh?
Now that she's alive again, she's probably still being
detained in the super super's office.
She won't be able to pursue her case without the freedom to
move around.
I'd better go back to the super's office to see her.
That sounds like a good idea.
Beep-boop.
The super's office.
Actually, you guys, I'm going to go to the bathroom real
quick.
I said I was going to go earlier, but now I actually have to
go.
I have to go to the little ghosties room.
Give me one minute.
I'm also going to get some more tea or coffee.
One or the other.
I'll be right back.
You can enjoy this sick soundtrack while I get more drink.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my god.
While I was getting my coffee, a package that I was waiting
for came.
Hold on.
I'm going to get some scissors.
I was waiting for this because I got stuff for my back.
Ouch!
I got
it!
This is the thing for me to try later.
For my neck!
I got two things for my neck.
But this one I lay on.
Oh, this one's heavy because it's cat food.
Hold on.
I got it!
Um...
Yeah, stuff for my spine!
Can't be!
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Yippee!
Okay, cat food!
Oh, thank goodness I was running out of cat food!
Yeah!
A
lot of stuff!
Oh.
I'm good.
Oh my god.
One bar support.
I feel like such an old person.
Oh!
Okay, there we go.
Um, I'm gonna open it.
I'm gonna put it on.
Wait, can I put it on right now?
Will it be too difficult to put on?
Also, I realized I didn't have any creamer either for my
coffee.
So it's just coffee and milk.
Oh gosh.
Grandma mint.
It's just because I have a...
I always get pinched nerves in my arms.
and in my I have sciatica that's a pinch nerve in your in
your butt so this product
can cause burns 55 or older your risk of burning increases
as you age do not wear while sleeping okay check Skin
frequently during use.
Do not use for more than eight hours.
Okay.
Actually that works perfect because...
You will burn as you age.
I'm in my 30s.
I just bought an adjustable bed base for backpan.
Embrace it.
Let's go!
Hey, there's nothing wrong with getting something for
comfort, you know?
And Draco thanks for the 10 gifted!
How do I put this on?
Uh, heat cells.
Guys, I'm gonna feel the deep penetrating relief.
Wait, which way do I put it on?
Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay, okay.
I think I get it.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna feel the deep penetrating relief that it says.
Clinically proven to relax tight muscles and enhance
flexibility and mobility.
Why do I sound like such an old person?
Oh my gosh.
You don't have to say it like that.
Okay, I gotta put it on my neck.
I don't feel anything yet.
Hey, I'm so glad that this came.
I need the relief.
So much pain, you guys.
Okay, I'm so sorry about that.
All right.
All right, we're good to go.
Let's go to the super's office.
The age of 3,000 isn't the man.
Hag love.
Deep penetrating relief.
I decided to go back to the office where Lynn was being
detained.
With her changed fate, her story was sure to change too.
And maybe that would lead us in some new direction.
Hags are love, hags are love.
This is the hag life, you guys.
Have a great summer and also have a healthy, have a
pain-free, summer with neck pain therapy deep penetrating
relief yeah now that Lynn is alive again I wonder what she's
doing she said she was investigating oh oh my god
investigating an important case tonight but that case be
connected to me in any way ha haps ghost hag arc begins oh
We cleared the challenge.
I'm still so curious what's going on in that guy's basement,
though.
Listen to the music.
Yeah.
Continue.
If you sleep on your side like I do, I had the same symptoms
type muscles on the shoulder, neck with bonus tension
headaches.
I'll do it all by sleeping with a pillow between the knees.
I can't, I try.
I seriously cannot sleep with a pillow between my knees.
It drives me insane.
too much in my sleep i think i had one before hag life is
either be warm forever or die also i can't um i i'm such a
particular sleeper oh my gosh okay so i can't have so much
pressure on top of me so like when um when when i have a
pillow in between my knees it makes it so that the sheets
are too tight and it feels like it's i'm not claustrophobic
but only only only when i sleep do i feel claustrophobic
because if i can't move around at at will then i feel like
i'm gonna die but but um daki macuras exist for a reason no
i can't use it that i only look at daki macura i don't know
i'm so so particular but at the same time I have to sleep
with all of my arms and legs and everything underneath a big
heavy comforter which makes no sense considering considering
how did you sleep in Japan with their comforters I was fine
it's so weird I love my comforter me too oh my gosh I felt
so seen the other because like you know how comforters and
like when you see the pictures of them they're so billowy
and puffy and you're just like oh my gosh this looks like
the fluffiest ever comforter ever and then when you get it
it's like flat and terrible and it feels like there's only
five down feathers in it and you're like what happened I've
been I've been scammed but I found out that there's like a
thing that you have to get to make them look fluffy I can't
remember what it's called though hood winked yeah hug your
snake dockey when you get it oh I am I am duvet cover it
might be that there was a different name too though anyway
when Lynn lost her life for the second time she was being
detained on suspicion of my murder but I saved her hoping to
solve my own mystery living creatures can choose to live
their lives in one of two ways.
They can either submit to their fate or they can try to
change it.
Lynn is definitely in the second camp.
Well, I mean, she's only trying to change it because you
brought her back.
It's you trying to change it.
Just Google fluffing.
Is that what it is?
No, I don't think so.
It's a different word.
this fact was really brought home to me what is fluffing do
not Google that wait what is that fool you we told you not
to let the suspect out of what is fluffing
not stream safe I'm googling it don't do it apparently no
Phil no don't look I'm not gonna look it up because I'm
scared.
I'm actually, I have no idea.
Preparation for a certain job.
What?
Fluffing.
What kind of yabai job would have you prepare for something
that would be called fluffing?
Does it have to do anything with being fluffy?
Like, um...
Like, you know, How some bigger people say I'm not fat and
fluffy?
No, oh, okay.
Certain video actors, A-B stuff, really?
What's related to A-B?
You fluff the relief, what does that mean?
I'm confused.
To keep you ready between shots.
I just don't understand.
Okay, I'm just gonna believe you guys.
I don't get it.
Gotta raise this flag before you sit still.
Oh, wait.
I think I get it.
Anyway...
How do you know?
How do you guys know that?
We told you not to let the suspect out of your sight!
My apologies, sir.
But I never thought she would run away.
Oh my god, she just ran!
She booked it!
Lynn is our angel.
I mean, her friend.
I mean, she's like family to us.
Angel, friend, or family.
They all run when they have the chance.
Because we're perverts.
It's okay, I like that about you guys.
A little bit.
Do you have any idea how many years it's been since my wife
ran away?
Holy moly!
Feeney, are you okay?
I'm very sorry.
I have no idea, sir.
You'll never make a detective at that rate.
Dang.
Now find Lynn.
Yes, yes, sir.
God.
gets word of this, it's all over.
This poor guy.
I can see why his wife left him.
So our red-headed detective escaped, did she?
But I just barely saved her a few minutes ago.
Whew, she's fast.
Wait, but where's the detective?
Cabanella.
I guess I'll look around for leads.
Her notebook, obviously.
Trick time!
Don't touch that dial.
Close.
No, it's going to open eventually.
Or...
Oh, hold on.
I want to get to that notebook up there.
So we're going to...
Oh, no, wait.
Wrong thing.
My bad.
Here.
If I turn this around...
Will the steam somehow push it up?
I don't know.
Lynn's notebook.
Sad and forgotten.
Sits behind the bookshelves.
Who could she have been calling on the phone before she hit
it there?
Wish I could find out.
Hmm.
Try Square Pillow as a side sleeper for...
I've looked into Squared Pillow.
Right now, I do have...
I do use a specific pillow.
I've always had back problems forever.
Even as a ghost.
Oh, everything is hard.
What's our guy doing over here?
Oh, there's more people!
I can't hear from here.
Better get closer.
Oh, okay.
Is she down here?
What's he saying?
That old pigeon man.
You suppose he is carrying out some sort of research here?
In fact, problems could be bone related.
Yeah.
I have bad...
Well...
I have...
Now it's like my bad bones transferred into my ghost life.
You know, it kind of sucks.
Look at all these precision instruments and complicated
devices.
Bear to the bone.
Bear.
Phantom pain.
What are you doing?
Sir, I think this might be how Lynn escaped.
Through here.
Through the poop chute.
She couldn't possibly fit in that tiny little elevator.
Why?
I don't know, sir.
Lynn is pretty slim.
Why are you checking her out, huh?
Don't you know that women can make themselves appear slim
through fashion?
You think if you had four minutes, you could at least die
with better bones?
Oh, my gosh.
Four minutes before my death, I just shove all the magnesium
down my throat.
The men found us out.
No, what do you mean through...
What are you talking about, Edgeworth?
I mean, prosecutor pain.
To this day, I still don't know how much my wife really
weighs.
You don't need to know that.
I'm very sorry.
I had no idea, sir.
You'll never make detective at that rate.
This poor guy.
Anyway, where is that old pigeon man?
Oh, him, sir?
He went through the door behind me, sir.
Oh.
That one right there.
That door, yeah.
It won't open.
Apparently that door leads to the basement, but it's
currently locked, sir.
I'm starting to get why his wife left.
These are two different guys.
Time to gotcha don't know timing again.
This one was sent on 822 JST.
A little over 10 minutes.
Like 15 minutes?
15 minutes not so bad these instruments they're all very
suspicious you'd better keep your eye on that old man too
yes sir if it involves a criminal wouldn't you like bash the
door down to try and get in there you know like okay so we
have examined these before but does he say anything
different now that Lynn's not here.
Pictures of little fragments of rock.
A little pigeon guy strange.
Tasting wild decor.
Okay, just a little bit.
What is this gonna heat up?
Oh!
Wait!
I can't... I can't attach myself to him anymore.
I can't...
Oh!
I could swear I just saw this thing move!
Don't tell me!
This is a bit!
I sense the tension between me and the detective and it
moved to get away from it.
I think the detective, I think, or not the detective, this
guy might be my favorite character.
Unnamed officer.
He's so funny.
I love unnamed officer.
That was an unexpected tangent.
I'll never make detective about this right now.
confidence in your soul!
No!
What I need is some sort of an achievement.
Achievement.
A feather in my cat.
If only I could find a helpful lead that might...
The book, the book, the book.
A helpful and blindingly obvious lead is staring.
You were in the face right now!
There you go.
I swallowed my spit wrong.
This is... Lin's notebook.
If I give this back to her, it might spark something
between.
Spark something between us.
What do you mean by that?
Isn't she your family, detective?
Um.
What do you mean by that?
Didn't you say she's your family?
She's an angel.
No, a friend.
A family.
What to do?
This is a very complicated It didn't matter.
No, don't let him take your accomplishment.
Don't let him take your accomplishment.
What have you got there?
What?
This?
Oh, this is...
Wait a minute.
Is that...
Yes, sir.
It's Lynn's notebook, sir.
Notebook, eh?
Come to think of it, there was something about that in the
report.
Something about her looking at her notebook and making a
phone call.
Don't let him take it from you!
This must be it.
This telephone number with a big circle around it.
Vivi Koi, thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Aren't you curious to know who she was calling?
I am.
It really am, sir.
I'd like to know.
Oh.
But I don't have any ulterior motive for wanting to know,
though.
No, sir, no, sir.
No, sir.
This number might be an important lead.
I'd better check it out.
This music is so Phoenix Wright.
Trick time!
When is this gonna go off, I wonder?
I can't examine it yet.
It's still closed.
I'd like to see what's inside.
But this guy has a death grip on it.
I can't open it.
I bet this detective never lets his prey escape once he gets
a hold of it.
Here we go!
To whom am I speaking, please?
Yes, hello?
This is a criminal investigation.
We need your cooperation.
Hey, I know that voice.
Is that you?
Detective McCaw?
What did I call him?
Detective... Detective McCaw?
Oh, is that Officer Bailey?
Detective.
What's up, sir?
You don't usually call this way.
Oh, uh...
Did she get a call from one of our detectives, Lynn,
earlier?
From Lynn?
Yes, I did.
She calls every night.
Maybe she senses it's about to happen.
What is about to happen?
Did she say anything special?
No, not really.
Is something wrong?
Ah, well...
Hold on.
I might be contacting you again if I have any other
questions.
Okay.
Trace complete.
To that place.
I'm going to go file the report down at the station.
I need you to be vigilant here.
Excuse me, detective, but...
What is it?
I know, why am I...
That guy's sitting...
He's avoiding the gamer posture, you guys.
Everybody...
That is peak sitting position.
Everybody should know that.
That's how I'm sitting literally right now.
You don't sit like that with your booty out and your chest
pushed forward like this.
Oh, yes.
This is peak performance, obviously.
Actually, let's all stretch.
Oh, yeah.
Ow!
Oh, my arm.
Sorry.
It's the pinch nerve.
Um, what was I saying?
Oh, that notebook.
Would you mind if I gave...
Oh, never mind, sir!
Humph.
Just stay on your toes.
Grandma Mint, are you okay?
Yeah, I'm fine.
I'm okay.
Trick time.
What is this gonna heat up?
Maybe when we come back.
Maybe I have to wait.
He almost did it.
You did.
Let's go to that new place.
New people.
Oh no.
Oh my gosh, the shrimp.
Was that...
What was that call about?
I heard you say Lynn.
Oh, why is it still like that?
I don't really know.
If I had to take a guess, though, I would probably say
something's going on with her.
Ha, ha.
The only place in the world where nothing is going on is
inside your brain, Bailey.
Oh, bird.
What is that supposed to mean?
I know what the words mean.
That's not what I'm asking.
That was my way of expressing indignation.
Putting it in the form of a question.
Oh.
Sits back so polite.
Is that guy drinking wine on the job?
I just hope Lynn's not doing anything crazy.
I'm a fan of hers, you know?
According to my law, is she not a real detective?
Is she like an actress?
Is she like an actress playing the role of a detective and
like she's not actually she doesn't actually know anything
just passed her test recently oh yeah it's so true according
to my log Lynn has been calling here nearly every night as
of late so let's see this is the place Lynn took all that
risk to call eh but what exactly is this place trick down
trick down Oh.
Oh.
Ah.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, the lever over there.
You see it on the bottom, right?
We can release all the inmates.
Be free.
Bro's posture.
Look at this.
Wow.
I didn't know I would need the eye tracker for this stream.
Late grants on 200K.
I'm so proud of you and you're freaking amazing.
Anikosu!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I don't think we can do anything here.
Except...
Except get an eye full.
I guess we'll go back.
Oh wait!
Oh!
Just kidding.
I can let the memo loose.
There's a phone over there too.
Let's examine this monitor.
The screen shows rows of tiny rooms.
The rooms are really, really small.
And you can see right into them from the outside.
I suppose the open bars couldn't keep...
Oh, the open bars keep the rooms airy.
But I wouldn't want to live in one myself.
I wonder where these little rooms are.
I wonder...
If I let myself go...
Woo-hoo!
Hey, what's this?
Oh, that?
I wrote down my duties for the night, so I wouldn't forget
any of them.
You can't keep them in your head.
It's not like you have a ton of duties.
Why did you put them in quotes like that?
After all, use a little brain power.
What are you talking about?
Weren't you the one who said nothing?
You guys, it's so jover when I get 3D and I can be able to
do that every time I make a mistake in a video game.
It's so over.
I can't wait.
Weren't you the one who just said nothing was going on
inside my brain?
Hmm.
Didn't think you'd take it quite...
wait didn't think you'd take it in quite that direction what
else are you saying so let's see this important to-do list
of yours nine take prisoner c38 to the telephone room yes he
just made a request to use the phone a little while ago nine
a that's when Lynn usually calls the chair spin yeah well we
can't let her talk to him tonight rules are rules.
Aw, poor Lynn.
Sure wish I could comfort her.
That's okay.
I've got it all memorized for you.
Well, it's your duty to guard the telephone room, you know.
Right there.
Just make sure you do your job when the time comes.
These guys are so goofy.
I love it.
He's gonna put up another memo.
Oh.
Moshi Moshi.
Is it Lynn?
Oh, it's Lynn!
Oh, spooky music.
Lynn!
I'm sorry.
I don't have much time.
Please let me talk to him.
I'm sorry, detective.
I can't do that tonight.
You can't?
But you always let me talk to him before.
Well, uh, the telephone room is already reserved.
That's why.
Or he's dead.
Dun, dun, dun, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Oh.
By the way, is something going on with you tonight?
What?
Why do you ask?
I got a call from one of the other detectives a minute ago
asking about you.
Oh, really?
Oh, well, I don't think it's anything important.
Officer Bailey?
Do you think you could keep this call just between us?
Even if only for tonight?
Well, I Oh, look at the time I gotta go, I'll call again
tomorrow
Dang, I didn't even say Bye, he hung up on her Mysterious
Place Oh boy, well I guess I'd better call the detective
Division, no!
Snitches, snitches, snitches
Don't do it, Officer Bailey Don't do Hold on there, Bailey.
Don't tell me you're going to report that call from Lynn.
What else can I do?
It's my duty.
Just write it down on one of your important to-do lists.
And then I can wad it up for you and throw it away.
You mean you want me to keep quiet about it?
Wow.
Well, isn't that what she asked you to...
Why were you...
eavesdropping on our call, huh?
Well, yes, but tonight is kind of a special case for us.
Can't you make a special exception for my...
What is
up with all these people claiming Lynn?
Lynn does not belong to all of you.
She belongs to me!
I won't let all of you, any of you have her.
Hands off!
Oh, Nen!
No, Lin!
Special case, huh?
Alright, you win.
Trick time.
Wait, so...
What is he gonna say?
I don't know what they think is special about tonight, but
for me, it's my only night.
Lin is on the other end of that telephone line.
I better hurry.
Yeah, I was gonna do his little memo, but...
I guess we'll go I guess we'll dial To here Hourlin No No No
way No Is it a rock I was gonna say a locked room case I
said a rock Is she dead again?
Lynn!
Oh, why could it have been me instead?
I'm no use as a police officer.
It should have been...
It should have been me!
Not her!
It looks like she's dead.
We'd better not touch her.
Who shot?
Why do you assume it's a shot?
A gunshot, huh?
Why do you assume that, officer?
Hey, excuse me, mister.
Sumi masun.
You talking to me?
Whoa.
This room.
There aren't any...
It is a locked room case.
There aren't any other exits besides this one, are there?
there?
Do you see one?
Well, there's like a hatch below.
Huh?
And how did...
We must have one of those mysterious locked room murder
cases on our hands!
Yippee!
Murder!
Yeah!
One of those cases where the murderer vanishes into thin air
in a vacuum.
Just go find a real detective.
It's Umineko, let's go!
I'll keep watch here.
No, there like a trap door in the middle of the room is this
guy not a suspect why are we letting him stay with the body
ah what a terrible turn of events so now a locked room
murder a things never get dull for our redhead I know of a
certain inspector who might dance around at the thought of a
mystery me but no mysteries for me not when I can rewind
time and talk to the victim herself guess it's time to go
back and see the truth behind this murder with my own eyes
beep beep beep beep I'm going ghost I'm going lamp I'm going
girl or goose haha I died again I thought you'd be a little
more grave under the circumstances this man she's not she's
not caring about her death at all she doesn't care she's
she's just like not when I have you around a rewind time I
died to hit pero I died so silly I died how
silly of me oh my gosh I just keep getting murdered that's
so silly of me yeah well this is the third time after all
it's scary what a girl can get used to don't you think
frankly the way her mind works is a whole heck of a lot
scarier to me just feeling a little guilty feeling a little
goofy might die tonight so what happened this time who shot
you I don't home.
Nani?
I'd like to know myself.
Who could have done it?
Who shot me?
Why?
What are you asking me for?
Oh boy.
Guess I'll have to go find out for myself.
Okay.
You just go do that.
Hurry along now.
I get the distinct impression I'm being used here.
Translator note.
Nani means what?
Okay.
Looks like it's time to go back.
Back to four minutes before your death.
Let's see.
She called.
844.
Lots of fours in this game, huh?
Okay.
She hears something going on.
Oh.
The doctor.
He looks really frightened.
How long has it been since I locked this room up in
darkness?
Okay.
He's a weird guy.
I thought I once thought the truth could be discovered in
darkness oh my god the Matroska dolls look so scary maybe it
was just that the time wasn't ripe yeah see there's a little
thing in the middle of the floor wait so it's not only just
a locked room case but it's also dark oh
she's hiding oh my god she can hide in there the guy was so
right She...
Oh my gosh.
That was so smooth.
With the power of fashion.
Mooshy mooshy.
He hung up.
Oh, it's boiling.
Ow!
His behind.
Okay, there's a lot going on here.
There's Henya!
Yeah!
Okay, goes into the dark room.
Tipy toe.
There's a lot of contraptions in here.
Uh oh.
Oh no, I don't think you should have done that!
Oh my god.
And it lights that on fire.
And then...
No way.
What?!
Don't just stand there!
It's a booby trap!
That's the truth behind our locked room murder!
Okay, I saw the gun up there and I thought that it would
probably be the thing that shot her, but that's...
We got home alone for real!
So the murderer was a mechanical murder machine!
The murder machine.
When I came into the room, it was pitch dark, so I turned on
the light.
That must have been what set it off.
The murder machine, I mean.
Can you please stop repeating the words murder machine?
That old pigeon guy must have made it.
But why?
What could be the meaning behind this?
He's trying to figure something out.
But he needs the...
He's hiding it.
If someone comes in to steal his research, they're going to
get murdered.
By the murder machine!
Anyway, you'll have to find some way to stop that creepy
machine.
Once Cupid fires his arrow, it's all over.
Rewind time.
Trick time.
Oh, we're starting from here?
Interesting.
What is it?
You know what, Cicel?
I think this death might be easier to prevent than the
others.
Why is that?
You know, because the murderer is mechanical.
She has- Did I just disconnect?
Am I good?
I'm good?
Oh, okay.
For a second.
Hmm.
Strange.
Sorry about that.
I can't manipulate living creatures, but I can manipulate
this machine.
Now I just gotta figure out how to stop it.
When the four minutes ago, me, turns on the light, that's
when the murder machine is set in motion, apparently.
So it looks like the key to solving this one is
understanding this device.
Which I think we kind of get.
Oh yes, locked up in the room in darkness, something,
something, this time is not right.
We can infiltrate the lamp.
Oh, interesting.
I don't think me going to...
Oh, wait, but no, no.
There's the motor up top.
We do have to go upstairs.
I think we have to wait for the guy to...
To call, and then we go through, right?
Wait.
Oh, the telephone isn't working.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Because there was the motor up top.
So we'll wait for it to ring.
Ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring,
ring.
And he slides down.
All cool time is passing.
Okay.
Is this the superintendent?
I'm so glad.
I thought I was all alone.
Go there.
Okay.
Okay, he hung up.
Trick time!
Okay, maybe we stop this from going off on your butt.
Oh!
And then you're gonna move it down here?
Oh, this poor guy!
This is the Shinji pose for real.
Oh my gosh, Lynn ran away.
The detectives yelled at me.
The old pigeon man ignored me.
Oh no, he's never going to become a detective at this rate.
And then the kettle nearly scared me to death.
My life is incomplete!
Shambles!
That's gratitude for you.
We were just trying to warn him with the kettle whistle.
Would he have preferred getting scalded by the steam?
Well, at least his fate was changed a bit.
in his butt that's good anyway the fate has been changed for
real okay so the ball okay how did it go again uh the
presence the the thing started spinning the fan started
spinning lifting the present and the ball spun over uh if uh
i can't tell what everything is because it's hard Okay, I'm
gonna have to Okay, here we go I'm gonna have to Be flung to
somewhere I have to be Flung wherever I have to Okay, hold
on Oh, oh, oh I'm the toolbox Open!
Okay, we went the wrong way Nice And, um Move the hoist I
don't know what this does.
Oh no!
No!
Oh my god.
Wait!
Oh, I messed up!
Maybe.
What did the bowling ball even do before?
Actually, I have no idea.
Uh.
I missed it.
Yeah, I think I did.
Uh.
Oopsie!
That's okay.
we can go from when the fate was changed the key to this
murder machine is that cheeky little cupid who fires the
arrow but we were close we were so close we were close we
were close we were close very tight timing yeah but wait a
minute that swinging shovel yes yes yes I wonder if that can
be used as a weapon somehow against our cupid guess I'd
better rewind yes after the fate change okay this trick to
feel long time when i first played it i think we're um it's
not so bad maybe maybe i hope not we'll see okay here we go
do
i need to what do i do with this though i
don't remember if the did the shovel like fling into the air
really fast
No spoil, no hints, no hints, no hints, no hints, no hints,
everybody, no hints.
Oh my god, I would do timing.
Oh, no, it doesn't.
It just...
Okay.
I'm trying to look at everything that I can possess.
Timing is everything.
Yeah, Lynn's gonna just keep getting blasted, man.
Um, think about the timing as well.
Yeah.
That's true.
Cookment, I believe you?
Sometimes it just takes me a second, okay?
Some people said it took them a long time to get started.
What is that thing behind the box?
I don't even know what that is.
The murder machine is started!
The whole thing plays out that gun will go off before that
happens.
I need to use my ghost tricks.
Must be some way to disrupt this domino effect.
I just have to find it.
Oh, wait!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think when the ball...
When the ball lands, I have to...
the ball landing to the shovel falling so it will so it will
go it will swing it up i think is what i have to do
oh my god maybe now
that was pretty good just now maybe if we were on a on a
putting green with a swing like that maybe we could put it
to use here good thinking i was just i just might be able to
use this trick somehow if i could change the path the ball
takes Change... Okay.
Change the path the ball takes.
That's great and all, but it looks like we're all out of
time this round.
Is it this?
What does this go to?
Oh, I guess I'll never know.
Hmm.
Okay.
We got this.
Okay, after the fight change.
Okay.
But what does the...
I still don't know what that thing down there is.
And would this be...
Wait, how would we change the direction?
How would we change the direction?
Wow.
Why doesn't Lynn dodge it?
Is she stupid?
Maybe a little.
Oh, I can't reach it.
Can I reach here?
I don't know if this does anything, but I'm going to try it.
Here we go.
Bend here.
And...
I don't know if this will do anything.
Open!
Oh, gosh.
No.
That didn't.
do anything.
How do I change it?
Um, I don't know if it will let me go back into the ball
when I push it.
But maybe, let's see.
Ride the ball after it's hit.
That's why I'm gonna see if I can do.
I don't know if it will let me if it counts as a cutscene or
if it will let me little bit i have no idea we'll see oh
before it falls no but i have to i have to open the toolbox
oh but you mean like wait
maybe like with the most tightest of timings oh no i
wouldn't let me ghost trick no oh no it won't let me No, let
me...
Yeah, it's a cutscene.
Hmm.
This one's tricky.
This one's kind of tricky.
This box...
I don't know how to reach it.
Unless...
Okay, hold on, let me try something.
Unless when the ball is on the table, I can go to it.
And then it does whatever it does.
I'm not sure what it does, but it might do something.
Oh no, it's just a toy cake!
Are you serious?
Wait!
Door, door, door, door, door, door!
Door!
There we go.
Oh, oh my gosh.
I thought it just set everything on fire.
What just happened?
Looks like your future just got a whole lot rosier.
Happy birthday!
Your death has been erased.
E-git!
I, uh, thank you.
You kept your promise, didn't you, Sissel?
My promise?
And now she can escape through the trap door.
You said I'd see you again if I died.
I don't remember making any promises.
It's all for my own benefit anyway.
Fate averse.
What could this room be all about?
I can't imagine.
Those things that went off at the end.
Those were party poppers.
Oh no, did they hear them?
Did they hear the potty pop?
What potty is the potty?
The party poppers!
I have no recollection of what they are.
But that's no surprise.
I said it with an accent, you guys.
The party poppers.
I just said it with an accent.
I didn't say party poppers.
I said the party poppers.
It's the party poppers.
The party poppers.
The gun going off.
It seems familiar somehow.
I'll leave that part of the puzzle to you.
I have my own puzzle to tell you.
figure out.
Well, shall we go back now?
Back to your new present?
Sayonara!
No saving this one, boss!
What do you mean?
Okay, now you can leave.
Or you can investigate what's going on in here.
Cicil, are you there?
Oh, she remembers me.
Lynn is talking to me?
Uh, If you're there, could you say something?
If you're not there.
I guess I'm just a weird girl who talks to herself.
She remembers.
Well, you are kind of a weird girl.
Whether you talk to yourself or not.
Trick time.
What do we say?
Talk?
Wait.
You are here.
I knew it.
I just had that feeling.
Wait, what?
Shame on you for stepping foot into a...
a girl's head uninvited.
Wait a minute.
Posh meant my beloved.
Don't give me that.
A ghost doesn't have feet, but I have feet.
Sometimes.
It's just a figure of speech.
It depends on how much energy I have.
How much ghostly energy I have, you know?
Yeah, but she did invite him.
So true.
Hey, did I say anything?
That tone, it's that tone of yours that makes me mad.
Oh, sorry, she has an accent now.
So did you have something particular you wanted to say to
me?
Hmm, in British.
I just thought I'd share some information with you.
I'm investigating a case right now.
A murder case, and I'm doing it alone.
A murder case, all by yourself?
Yes, well, that's because the case was closed.
long time ago the culprit is already behind bars forgotten
by the world I think it's the lamp I think it's the lamp
making amends so why are you look or the person that was
murdered by the lamp I mean the guy behind bars so
why are you looking into it then because I think the
person's innocent that's why There's something strange
behind the case.
Some big mystery.
I firmly believe that.
So anyway, I finally have my memory back.
I'm not at liberty to tell you about the case.
But if there's any...
I'm so sorry if you're British, by the way.
Because you're British.
And also because I'm probably really butchering this accent.
But if there's anything else you want to know, I'll try to
answer what I can.
We deserve it.
No.
Played by Emma Watson.
That's who I'm channeling.
Lynn is my only lead.
I would like to ask her about a few things.
About the girl with the bow.
Oh, yeah.
What about about the dog?
You have your life and your memory back now.
So let me ask you again.
Who shot me tonight?
Yeah, I thought that might be the first time.
thing on your mind what else would it be there's a good
chance i was shot while i was with you after all i'm afraid
my memory just isn't clear on that part not clear i met with
you tonight and then you fell down right in front of me i
think i remember seeing that part i'm pretty sure you were
shot maybe from somewhere far away two steps ahead so you
didn't see the culprit I'm sorry I wish I could be a more
help but I know I wasn't the one who shot you your
colleagues seem to think you're a suspect though I wanted
the information you had for me so why would I shoot you
before I got it so true information huh I wonder what info I
had for her.
It's me.
I was the murderer.
About the dog.
Oh, dang.
About the girl with the bow.
By the way, I see you have a little roommate.
Camilla, how do you know about her?
There was a tiny incident at your apartment a little while
ago.
An incident?
What kind of incident?
What happened?
Is Camilla alright?
She's fine, thanks to her loyal little friend.
Missile!
Yeah, Missile is a good boy, Missile, Missile.
Although I did have a little trouble bringing him back to
life.
Oh my, oh, it's horrible.
Oh my god.
Bloody hell.
What in the world is going on?
Why would anybody target to hurt Camilla and Missile?
You're being targeted by a certain organization.
Missile mention, yeah!
What?
I saw them.
The people who were calling you their target.
So I'm a suspect and a target.
Could this night possibly get any worse?
This sound pretty rough.
Are you sure you'll be okay on your own?
Englishman is killing me.
Sorry.
Huh?
You know what they say.
When it rains, it pour.
Isn't it time you admitted you need me?
Need my powers?
I'm sorry.
I can't cooperate with you.
Yes, you saved my life tonight.
Three times!
I'm completely grateful for that.
But as a detective, I still can't trust you.
That's too bad.
And about the information.
the dog so i had some important information that you wanted
huh i think i feel like you could trust me even more because
i have no memory right levio saw that's right you called the
station yesterday and you asked to talk to me you told me
you had an important lead on the case i was walking walk i
was working on important lead you said you you said you
wanted to meet me and talk to me directly tonight at the
junkyard important and you fell for it even given how fishy
it sounds you're the last person i want to hear that from
you know but i just couldn't let it go no matter how shady
it seemed i'm walking here that's because i'm running out of
time Oh my god, are they gonna kill that guy in the jail?
Okay, that's right.
You said something was going down tonight.
Is he gonna die?
Does that something have to do with the case you're working
on?
I'm sorry, but I can't talk about it.
You stop!
Stop being so mysterious!
Oh boy.
But I guess I understand.
Death sentence, maybe.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Let's stop dilly-dallying here.
So what are you going to do now?
Bren, I guess.
They'll catch me again if I don't get out of here.
What is this accent?
I don't even know anymore.
And I have to get to the restaurant.
I'm worried about Camilla.
Oh yeah, what was it?
The chicken kitchen on Dead End Drive, right?
What about you, Sissel?
What are you going to do?
I'm going to follow you.
I don't know to tell you the truth.
You're my only lead.
If you leave...
Yeah, feel guilty.
Feel bad.
I just saved your life three times.
I just realized you and I are in the same boat.
We're both looking for answers tonight, and neither one of
us has anybody to help us.
Why do you have an accent again?
Hey, even if you can't cooperate with me, how about if we
just agree to use each other?
Oh!
That's not a bad idea.
You're on.
But can I ask you to do a favor for me first?
What's that?
I need you to sneak into a certain place for me.
A prison, to be exact.
The prison!
Prison, prison, prison!
That's the place I was calling from the office upstairs.
I want you to go find out a certain prisoner's work schedule
for tomorrow.
Uh-oh.
I don't know.
I don't like the sound of this.
Work schedule.
For a prisoner?
Yes.
The prisoners are given different job details every day.
Each prisoner's schedule for the next day is written on a
small blackboard in his set.
So just go check out a certain prisoner's blackboard, huh?
Okay.
His prisoner number is D99.
Do.
If you do that for me, I'll cooperate with you.
Okay, you're on.
Here.
Let me give you the chicken kitchen's telephone number.
All right.
Easy.
Chicken kitchen.
Oh.
Where are we now?
Smell you later.
See ya.
But don't die again, if you can help it.
Oh, we're in the sewer.
Oh, lamb!
He's like, yippee!
It looks like I hold the key to the case Lynn is
investigating.
And she holds the key to solving the mystery of me.
So we've started up a strange relationship of cooperation.
Lynn gave me an assignment.
My task is to go check out tomorrow's work schedule for
prisoner D-99.
I'd better get to the prison.
Yippee, but un-grandpa boys.
I love this little contraption he has going on in here.
But what is he researching?
It's the stuff with the rocks, right?
Hmm, there's so many, like, parts of this game.
I'm not really cooking much.
I don't really cook much in games.
I kind of just, like, like, to...
to be surprised, you know.
Oh, it's 9.03 p.m.
Secret Seeker, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Yeah, just go with the flow.
Lost memories of self.
A forgotten murder case.
A dead guy and a detective joined forces to find out the
truth behind them both.
Everything is so disjointed at the moment anyway.
Yeah, true.
The detective assigned the dead guy a task task.
To sneak into the prison and find out a certain prisoner's
schedule for tomorrow.
I like this music here.
What should I care?
I don't have a schedule for tomorrow.
That's how I'm feeling about it at the moment.
Trick time!
Oh.
All right, let's get back to a phone here.
That's why this moves.
Sneaky.
Sneaky, sneaky.
Oh.
Our detective.
Oh my God.
It's all over.
It's all over for me.
Lynn.
Sweet, cute Lynn who shines as bright as the sun.
Ran away on me.
And then those detectives matching bookends.
blue and green yelled at me oh forget all about that now you
listen to me kid yes you are bright as the Sun Lynn probably
doesn't even know you exist oh my god wait no this is like
your your streamer doesn't even know you exist no
one second and those detectives will probably yell at you
your whole life oh my God, getting true real.
Never mind fretting about every little setback.
Enjoy your life.
Get what you can out of it.
Mr. Would you mind just leaving me alone?
Aw.
Oh!
Shoot.
Sorry.
I just put a toothpick, some chapstick.
But I thought it was emptier than it really was and just
splat all over my lips.
now it's all over my finger
my lips are going to be the most hydrated ever do we even
exist mint uh who are you just kidding uh who are you guys
mint doesn't even know who i am uh who are you
who are you she forgot about um All I'm thinking about is
Missile.
I want to know what's in that book so bad!
Time to go to the prison.
Oh.
Oh, we can go to the chicken kitchen.
No, but we have a job to do.
Uh, wait.
Oh, here, uniform and all, there we go.
Do you think Missile will be at the chicken kitchen?
Mint would never reach out.
this uh what did that say so how are the preparations coming
along i think they're taking care of them right now yeah man
i'm not looking forward to this that kind of surprises me
coming from you i didn't know you thought about such things
by the way that was me being sarcastic just in case you
didn't catch that check the apartment for missile no missile
left the apartment Missile busted down the door and bolted
away, didn't it?
Two more hours.
And then it's time.
Oh my god, we're gonna go check their jail cell and it's
gonna say nothing on their work.
Oh my god, it's gonna say works for tomorrow.
Death.
Oh my god!
I guess we should just get back to work.
Yeah, I guess you're right.
Oh my gosh, I don't want to do death tomorrow.
The atmosphere sure seems tense.
I guess I'll just get back to my work as well.
Find out a certain prisoner's work schedule for tomorrow.
Blah, blah, blah.
Each prisoner's schedule for the next day is written on a
blackboard in a cell.
D99, everybody.
Alrighty then.
How do I get to these cells?
I'd better try to get some information here first.
Trick time!
have this memo and this memo and the monitors maybe now that
we know what's going on on the monitor we can check it tiny
rooms really small okay no we've read that before what's
this memo three oh no not let loose I like the way he holds
it what is it hey Bailey try
pinning up your memos a little better next time let me see
this thing inspection prisoner c74 well it's almost time for
that i'd better prepare prisoner c74 eh what did that big
whale do it dang i can't believe you can be thrown in jail
for a gotcha addiction that's kind of messed up you don't
know about the metro police department
C-74 barricaded himself into the Metro Police Department and
took siege of the place.
He even pointed a huge flamethrower at the Chief
Commissioner.
Damn!
C-74!
Why the heck did he do all that?
That's what the detectives who surrounded him asked, too.
What are your demands, they asked.
And?
Oh my god, he said, More free poles!
The gotcha, the write-up is a lie!
The guy looked confused, thought about it for a while, and
said, Bring me five servings of curry and rice.
On the double!
Curry and rice?
That's it?
Unfortunately, no.
After he was done eating, he torched the commissioner's
office with the flamethrower.
Torched it good.
Important documents and the commissioner's mustache were
destroyed by the flames.
Not the mustache!
Comrade!
What the heck did he do all that for?
Because the curry was too spicy, he said.
The Fury's... This is the Fury's origin story.
It was too spicy and I just lost it, he said.
The case sent shockwaves throughout the country.
But it doesn't make any sense in the first place!
How did a huge armed guy make it all the way into the
commission?
office alone it's a complete mystery what why don't they
just ask c74 himself maybe they did but they didn't they
hadn't released anything about it with his huge arms
apparently it's all a matter of national secrecy hmm
interesting I Why did he do that?
Why'd you quit throwing my important duty memos away?
Okay.
Is he gonna put another one up on the board?
Is this the same one as before?
I was hoping that I could possess the paper ball when he
threw it, so I could check the second monitor, but it won't
let me.
Hey, Bailey.
I think this guy has a southern accent.
What's the matter?
You can't even pin up a memo properly?
Let me see this thing.
Take prisoner C-38 to the telephone room.
Yes, he just made a request to use the phone a little while
ago.
You already told me that earlier.
C-38, eh?
You can move before you press the bubble.
Oh, I can?
In Japan, a death row's inmate execution date is not
revealed until the day of.
I think that's why Lynn was asking his tomorrow the day.
I didn't know that, interesting.
But, see, that's what I think.
He also was on Death Row.
I think so.
Oh.
What did that punk do anyway?
You never heard the story about the secret rendezvous case.
Ooh, la la.
Secret.
Who, what?
C38 was a singer and a band.
His group was playing a concert that was being broadcast all
over the country live.
And right in the middle.
of their encore there was a huge incident a huge incident
what was it a murder or something in a way it was even worse
than a murder because it had to do with national secrets oh
my gosh he said the launch codes in a song two five four
seventy three one one eight add a two square root of eighty
one five five five and your mom's birthday that is the
launch codes to the missiles and to cause all the doom i'm
gonna get thrown in jail huh national secrets a rock band
i'm lost before the stream cuts out oh i didn't even say the
best part the best part the best part say that's the launch
codes if you figured it out you're a genius and then you can
take over the world yeah so I gave you the key everybody you
just gotta go on lock the lock the song that they were doing
was called secret rendezvous but the The lyrics C38 was
singing were completely different from usual.
So how is that a huge incident?
Oh my god, deep throat.
Because the new...
Oh, sorry.
The new lyrics expose all the nation's dark...
Seamy secrets.
Does he mean steamy?
That was clever.
What, the launch code?
Yeah.
The last part's a doozy, isn't it?
Budget misappropriations.
strategies, elicit dealings, everything.
Seamy is a word?
Oh, it is.
First Mint blows the whistle on Boeing, then she reveals
launch codes.
She's a rebel.
Mint played as like a damn fiddle.
What are you talking about?
He was caught red-handed in the act of leaking national
secrets.
You were so silly, Peter.
Thanks to the pink!
Seriously?
The case sent shockwaves throughout the country but it
doesn't make any sense in the first place how would a rock
singer know any top secret information it's a complete
mystery oh my gosh there's so many mysteries here oh my gosh
what why don't they just ask c38 himself maybe they did but
they haven't released anything about it apparently it's all
a matter of national secrecy okay she's gonna put up more
memos though right
Would you quit throwing my important duty memos away?
Okay, Fushigir.
Okay, here's a new one.
Here's a new one.
Hello.
Hey, Bailey.
Okay, here I can ghost.
Oh, I can operate the emergency switch.
Let me see this thing.
Bring dinner to prisoner D-99!
Uh-oh.
Is it his final meal?
The chief is preparing it for him right now.
Uh-oh, it's his final meal!
Ooh, how fancy.
That's why they're preparing it!
D-99, eh?
Even I know about this one.
Yeah?
Such a sad case.
Hard for us, too.
his wife didn't he right in front of a family member the
music it's just awful why in the world did he do it what
would be your final meal I don't remember what my final meal
was I don't know what I ate last before I died hmm maybe
why would he why would he do something like that of all
people the mode of everything all a complete god these
detectives suck they can't figure out anything everything's
a complete mystery it's just ridiculous it doesn't make
sense that you would do anything like that i don't know the
details but apparently this case is a matter of national
secrecy as well i don't get it none of it makes any sense
You do know what kind of prison this is, don't you?
No.
It's a special prison built for these kinds of special
cases.
That D-99, who knows what he's thinking or hiding behind
that beard of his.
I don't like any of it.
I had my money on the exploding pies from SpongeBob.
I knew I couldn't take my job seriously without it getting
to me.
So the prisoner I'm looking for D-99 was convicted of
murder.
And he apparently has a beard.
Oh my god.
Ew.
Ow.
Would you quit throwing away my board duty memos?
All right.
It's time.
Wait, I've heard that sound before.
Up.
Oh, it's the rock star!
Oh my god!
Why did they allow him to have a guitar in prison?
It's a stock sound?
Okay, I'm like where have I heard that sound, that door
sound before?
Oh, he finished putting up a thing!
It's done!
Emergency!
Oh, that's a lot of guns.
Oh my god.
Wait, is that like a...
Is that like a grenade launcher?
There you go again, fooling around with that thing!
A bazooka?
It was in May.
Don't lie, you...
Oh no, you love to see me jump and prepare for emergency.
Oh yeah, sure.
Way back when I first got this job.
But I've had enough of that now.
Besides, you always react exactly the same.
Girl!
The emergency switch is probably just...
loose probably because I fooled around with it too much well
it's for emergencies don't play with it anyway it wasn't me
maybe you ought to get it repaired huh dang I'm back I'm so
sorry you guys for anyone watching the VOD um we just had a
bit of a hiccup here we're back hopefully it is for good I
just I just stopped on the night vision goggles and I
laughed about it and then and then OBS crashed it was it was
the night vision goggles is fall I was like I was like no
way night vision goggles oh it is a bazooka more night
vision goggles oh wait we can check the okay anyway back to
business okay we can't check that monitor but can we oh we
still can't reach that one either can i operate the bazooka
no yeah sorry about that guys
oh i can go here camera button door let's try pressing this
oh
wow that's very tricky timing okay okay press okay there we
go there we go nice
so this is the thing that was making that horrible noise a
second ago am i still am i back you guys i can't tell
refresh if you're having having issues
i can't tell if i'm back i think my chat is dead hold on
screen
i think it's because uh
Oh, no, chat is all messed up on screen.
Oh, there it is.
I think OBS crashes when it, like, doesn't get a good
connection to YouTube.
You shouldn't have given us the launch codes.
Yeah, you're so right.
I think maybe I jinxed myself by stopping my own stream
earlier.
I mean, I didn't do anything of this.
Wait, how long have I been streaming?
Okay, almost three hours.
I wanted to go longer.
I'm just nervous about...
Let's just go a little bit longer.
Because I wanted to play so much today.
I wanted to go longer today.
We'll see how if it acts up again.
But since it disconnected earlier, too, I'm just kind of
nervous.
I guess it's a way for this spiky-haired youth to express
himself.
Sentiments like, I'm hungry.
Or I'm thirsty, maybe.
Like that, I bet.
Peace out.
I'm done.
Turn up.
Hoop, hoop, hoop, hoop.
Hoop, hoop.
All right, C-38.
Back to yourself.
Hey, guard man.
How about giving me a little space?
That crazy walk of yours is doing...
Yours is dangerous, man.
Hoop, hoop.
A proper walk for a properly led life.
Now let's go.
Yo, no lectures, man.
I walk my own path.
My own way to my own music.
I'm going to blame the Patriots.
Me too.
And we're inside the guitar, so we get to go into the jail,
so...
Where's our beard?
Oh, that guy has a beard.
I can't tell if that guy has a beard.
So I finally made it to the cells.
Now to find Prisoner D99 and check out his work schedule for
tomorrow.
What could Lynn possibly want with that information?
This game is the GOAT!
Watching a blind playthrough is a lot of fun.
I wish I can re-experience it for the first time again.
Hope you enjoy!
Thank you!
I always feel that was...
Like, I of course feel that way with Metal Gear.
But it's like, at the same time, I'm so glad that I played
it.
If I had never played it, then I would never have
experienced it once to begin with.
Don't think I can take another second in this stinking pit
Dang, he has all his instruments and everything Looks like
the guard man is gone
All this weighting is wiping me out Hope this one will
finally do it
Oh Oh my god, he's sending the launch codes through Code
Come on, sausage head What?
What?
This is a lenient prison.
For real, I was just thinking like they allow basketballs,
they allow...
Like, this guitar is so spiky it should be considered a
weapon.
This prisoner obviously isn't the one I'm looking for.
Prisoner D-99 has a beard.
There's one of those little blackboards Lynn said would be
in the cells.
Maybe I should check out Spiky's schedule for tomorrow.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Ew, I can examine his toilet.
Let me just give it a little read.
Tonight, I lost a lot of things.
My life, my memory.
But there's a certain skill I've apparently lost.
No, we don't know how to read!
I can't read!
Oh, God, I can't read!
I can see that there's some kind of...
But I have absolutely no idea what it means.
I can't read.
If I can't read Prisoner D-99's work schedule for tomorrow,
what do I do now?
What
is this?
Oh, this telephone.
Looks like it's an internal line only.
It doesn't call outside the prison.
So the only places I can go with this telephone are other
phones within the building that I've already possessed.
Oh, nice though.
Um, I can't read.
Oh my gosh, I can't read.
Oh.
Empty prison.
Looks like there's...
I cannot tell if the line going down...
What if I just press the emergency button?
An emergency button.
An emergency.
In a prison.
That's gotta be a pretty bad situation.
I'll give it a little try.
Time to cause chaos.
Uh-oh.
Oh, he just told him no, no, no.
Where do I go from here?
I think I have to cause that and then go through the note,
maybe?
Hmm.
What is this?
Oh, I can play the drum.
Hey, quit that racket!
This music almost sounds like Pokemon, like, battle music,
doesn't it?
Oh, wait.
I think through here I can see.
see what's going.
It won't let me move around.
That's kind of weird.
It really lets me see what's going on on the screen.
But I'm trying to move and it won't let me move.
Oh!
They moved him!
Wait a second.
Wait a second?
Oh, well, that's not our guy anyway, right?
Oh, and also this counts as a cutscene.
Go, go, go!
What's going on?
Does this count as a beard?
This guy has a beard?
Both of them have a beard.
Why is this guy a baby?
Why does this guy have...
The large... What is this guy?
Oh!
His head is so wobbly.
I don't think I...
Oh my god!
Prison break!
This guy was accidentally attached to the thing, and I
didn't realize.
By the looks of him, that must be the curry lover from the
police department's siege case.
But never mind that, where did he go?
What is going on in this cell?
There's a little blackboard here, too.
Just to be safe, maybe I'd better check the curry lover's
schedule for tomorrow, too.
But I can't read.
You solved it by accident?
Well, I knew what I had to do, but I didn't realize I was,
um, I didn't realize I was, uh, uh, possessing the, the,
the, the note.
I still can't read.
But I better go check out Prisoner D99 cell anyway.
Maybe I can find some kind of information that might help
Lynn out.
Besides, I want to see what this Prisoner Lynn is
investigating looks like.
Oh, I can't get over there.
Uh-oh.
Ringling!
Come back, mister.
Come back, come back.
His spoon.
Phew!
Oh, nice.
Thank you, sir.
Same thing here.
It doesn't call outside.
Other phones within the building that I've already
possessed.
Well, we've possessed this one.
one now so we're good okay here we are oh he's an artist oh
hmm with a what is that on the wall what a strange cell and
the prisoner inside it he seems to be enjoying himself sorry
i'm invading your private time this is the last cell in this
area so that means that this himself must be prisoner d99
according to what the guards say oh yeah recap he shot his
wife in front of a family member what in the world really
happened hmm and why is Lynn so concerned about this
prisoner I don't know the answers and I guess there's no
need for me to know I have only one of Objective.
And that's to find out what this painter's work schedule is
for tomorrow.
Trick time!
Picture frame.
Okay, open that up.
What's it?
I wonder if these are his family.
Oh my gosh, that's kind of gruesome, though.
Oh my god.
It's my wife and a giraffe!
My children!
My child is a giraffe!
Why is the left picture a giraffe?
Oh my god.
I wonder if these are of his family.
This one looks like a young woman holding a baby.
Oh!
You guys see the giraffe?
You guys see the giraffe right?
Oh, I know.
Oh, I could see it?
Oh.
Their faces have been blotted out with black paint.
Oh, so the baby is definitely Lynn, right?
Did he do it out of hatred or some other emotion?
Thankfully, that's not something I need to know right now.
She definitely became a detective to figure out her dad's
situation.
A newspaper article has been cut out in frame.
Unfortunately, I can't read it.
I'm stupid!
I'm dumb!
I'm so dumb!
It's probably about D99's case.
Man, murder his wife or something like that.
Why would you frame that, though?
There's a picture of the alleged culprit in the article.
Yep, it's this prisoner, alright.
Okay, moment of truth.
The work schedule for tomorrow of prisoner D99.
It's gonna be...
Okay, the reason we don't need to know how to read is
because it's going to be empty.
Oh my gosh.
We don't need to know.
It's going to be empty.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
The information Lynn's been looking for should be written on
this blackboard.
Unfortunately, I've lost the ability to read.
But here I am anyway.
The least I can do is take a look.
Huh?
What could this mean?
There's nothing written on the board!
Oh no!
Oh my god.
No work tomorrow!
Oh gosh, he has death tomorrow!
I think something was written on the blackboard.
I think something was written on the blackboards of the
other prisoners.
But this blackboard is as clean and blank as the day it was
hung there.
I knew it.
So I have the answer Lin was looking for.
work schedule for prisoner d99 is nothing oh would this
information mean anything to her it's not up to me to know
or care that's how i feel at the moment anyway oh and then
they're cooking his final meal i'm jealous oh my gosh mister
not being able to read i was wondering how this was going to
turn out some things in this world can be read even if one
can read can't oh even if one can't read no one can read
prisoner d99's work schedule for tomorrow is blank i'd
better get this important information to lynn as fast as i
can
uh close oh dinner
quite a feast tonight i see whoa he's huge he's the he's the
literal chat meme my gosh this guy is the Chad meme he's a
huge he cuts out of the frame and I'm absolutely crazy about
this chicken oh he's smiling it's too bad it's all cold and
hard though I'd say it's been about two hours since it was
cooked judging from the way it feels.
D99?
I know it's kind of pointless to ask now.
But just the same.
I still want to know.
Why did you do it?
I agree.
It's pointless to ask now.
My case is colder than this chicken and has been forgotten
by everybody.
Myself included.
Detective Chao!
He was a detective!
Now then, let me eat in peace before it gets too cold to
cut.
Why did they take so long to serve him as dinner?
Oh, that is art.
There's one more thing I've been wondering for a long time.
What's that?
Is it about Lin?
Your daughter?
Oh, who was the man in that painting?
Oh, this?
It's the culprit.
Well, being in prison like this, you start to forget faces,
you know?
So I paint the faces that I don't want to forget.
And this is the last of those faces.
Could you leave me alone for a bit?
Wait!
What?
Let a man eat in peace.
Okay, sure.
Sorry to bother you.
We must have...
Did we work together?
What's going on?
Wait.
Our hair is so similar.
I don't know.
Are we brothers?
What's going on?
Partners.
Yeah, like, were we detective partners?
Were we...
I don't think we were detective partners, though, because
they would have known we were detectives together.
I don't know.
I think we were brothers!
What in the world?
What in the world could this mean?
Why is there a painting of me in this man's cell?
Oh, my God.
Who exactly is this prisoner?
The man whose case Lynn is investigating is painting a
picture of me in his cell.
If only he could read.
to go see lynn fast not for her sake for mine to solve this
mystery of me
eat the chicken napkin bottle
that's me all right we know we can get to her by going
through the phone doesn't connect to the outside and I've
got questions I want to ask Lynn yeah we go to the office
gotta get to a place that has an external line and fast yeah
yeah I know I know the guard room
mochie mochie this is headquarters what's the status over
there oh chief it's ew they're making preparations now no
problems sir oh How much longer, then?
One more hour, sir.
I see.
Can't really...
One more hour?
Oh, one more thing.
What is it, Columbo?
Inspector Cabanella wishes to speak to you.
I think Cabanella is the guy who's done everything.
I think it's him.
I think he's going to do a switch on us.
Evening, Cabanella here.
How are your boys doing?
Hubba.
Inspector Cabanella, fine, sir.
You got another little call tonight, didn't you?
From my baby.
Oh.
From Lynn?
Uh, well, yes?
No!
Bailey!
You weren't supposed to snitch!
Chief has his dogs out.
What do you mean?
Do my girl have anything?
Interesting to say.
Uh, not especially.
She hung up almost immediately.
I see.
Next time she gives you a buzz, be sure to let me know right
away.
That's a good fellow.
Yes, sir.
You try to cover it up and I'm sure you'll regret it very
much.
Very much.
Thank you very much.
Yes, sir.
I'll call you right away, sir.
Immediately.
I can kind of see, I can catch glimpses of his feet.
don't forget she's a fugitive after all yes sir carry on
then I might pop in a little later yes sir looking forward
to seeing you sir oh my god his feet yeah his shoes are off
why why did you ride her out you dummy dumb
inspector Cabanella seems to be looking for her too you're
Lynn I mean Inspector Cabanel.
What would that special investigation unit want with Lynn?
I don't know.
I guess something happened that we don't know about.
Tonight, of all nots.
Damn.
He really is barefoot.
Let's put it on the feet, Wiki.
No!
Do you guys mind if I grab some more water real quick?
I drank all my coffee.
I just want some hot water for my throat.
And I'm going to get a little snack.
But it'll be fast.
just give me like one minute one minute to go get some drink
i'll be right back i'm so sorry for taking two breaks i'm
sorry i'm
back and i have a guest i have a special guest who decided
to join me
pies pies what you doing in here you silly girl what are you
doing in here pies i got some oh they're wet why is it so
wet that container that's wet why is my cat she's here oh
what are you getting into no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no hold
on guys i'm so sorry one second oh gosh i need to put my
food down but i don't know where to put it oh my gosh
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
She really said, Ben, Ben, Ben, Ben, Ben, Ben.
Sometimes, I know it's, uh, I know it's, like, with Merrill.
But sometimes I like to be like, You said you'd be a good
girl.
I, um, how's it?
Inspector Cabanela must be upset tonight, too.
Mmm!
Weren't he in Prisoner D99?
Detective Jowd?
Good friends?
Oh, oh.
Cabanella definitely did it then.
He was jealous of something.
He was jealous of the wife who he...
That's why he calls Lin his baby.
I think.
Oh, I think.
Are you sure about that?
They were such good friends.
How come Inspector Cabanella never came to visit him?
He's a head of a special investigation.
He's a very busy man.
You couldn't be that stylish and a bad guy.
Oh, no.
What's wrong?
Jowd was my hero, you know.
I wanted to be a detective because of him.
But look at me.
Rotting away in a place.
Oh, rotten away in a place.
This guy does have a southern accent.
Grouting away in a place like this.
Wait, how do I do a southern accent?
And I can't even do anything to help Lynn.
What am I doing with my life?
This new side of you is kind of endearing.
Oh my gosh.
Are you developing a crush?
Anyway, the thing to do is work at fixing what you can.
Little by little.
Like, for example, your house of cards.
Collapsed, you know.
Can love Blue.
Even in the prison office.
Lynn should be heading for the chicken kitchen now.
Call from the police headquarters intrigues me, too.
It's looking pretty obvious right now.
That white-suited inspector suspects Lynn.
And she's being considered a fugitive.
This is not good.
should go check in on the chief and the inspector in white
too uh i think we should get the information to her first
right oh wait dial dial dial dial uh external line oh my
gosh we're getting so many places now is lynn the only woman
in this world i know right i think she's the oh no besides
the the roommate she is the only other girl we've met i
think right oh oh and the mom that That fancy lady.
The chicken kitchen.
This is where that little lady and Lynn are supposed to
meet.
But.
I don't see either one of them here.
Yeah, and her daughter.
So, so true, so true.
Guess they haven't shown up yet.
It's been so much time.
What do you mean they haven't shown up?
This music is so funky.
There's someone singing.
In my right ear.
Sorry, I'll quiet it down.
Yeah, pipe down there, Mr.
I would like some service.
Alright.
I guess we have to go to the other place before.
They're forcing me.
They're forcing me to go to here.
Before we can experience chicken diners.
Fine chicken dining.
Mm-hmm.
In the long.
Oh, his toes!
Preparation seemed to be going smoothly over at the prison.
A.
Inspector Cabanella.
We were just a little too late.
So close, eh, Inspector?
We still have a little time left, Chief.
Not much, but some.
We've had point X around it all night.
If he shows up, we nab him, and we can still make it.
If he shows up, the real murderer of the wife?
But then why would you even tell that guy that he's going to
die?
tomorrow unless he has nothing on his board because he's
getting away free they're letting him out by the way what's
going on with that other case the junkyard murder she did it
eh no question about it I don't want to
read she's been a bad little baby Disappeared from the scene
like that.
Wonder where she ran off to play.
No!
What did he just say?
She did it.
Did I hear that right?
I think they were talking about the culprit who killed me.
No way.
No way!
Trick time.
Can I possess his feet?
Good lord.
What is this?
Ooh!
I just don't believe it.
Why would she do a thing like that?
Afraid I don't have the answers for you, Chief.
I don't want to believe it any more than you do.
And yet...
Stream had a hiccup again?
Hmm...
I wonder why there's so many issues tonight.
Oh, no hiccup here?
After seeing this, maybe we don't have any other choice but
to believe, baby.
Set the security.
security camera tape the investigation unit just delivered I
can't deny it's some pretty solid evidence against her watch
the tape is going to be this is some actual Phoenix Wright
shit where the the tape will be like them standing each
other talking and then it cuts out and then she's like
holding his body because the actual murder part gets gets uh
gets deleted somehow
Nothing like it, baby.
It's okay, they're just fries.
I can eat them with my fingies.
I was just trying to avoid greasy hands.
Why a murder case now on such an important night?
Put your feet, I mean, put your...
Put your shoes on, man.
Come on.
I think you have that wrong, chief.
Mm-mm-mm-mm.
chopsticks are for fries.
Okay.
I didn't want to say it was one of those gaming chopsticks.
You know those ones that you like put on your fingers so
that you can so that you can type on your keyboard?
So I just called it a fork.
Because I was embarrassed to say, oh, I dropped my gaming
chopsticks.
No, dang it.
And then you guys start calling me out for it being a fork.
work so no you guys know what i'm talking about right so you
put them in between like your index and your middle finger
and it like sticks there it stays there and then you can
like with your knuckles you like can you can um so you can
type and also have the chopsticks on your fingers
the little tweezers looking things yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're like barely chopsticks at all
That's what I was using.
I was embarrassed to say it.
Now I think I'm even more embarrassed.
Trying to imagine.
Let me see if I can get a picture real quick.
Oh, no.
I hate this image so much.
Okay.
This is what they're like.
This is what they're...
This
is what I was using.
Advanced Gamer Yeah, because I was holding my controller And
And eating my fries
Now you know I'd be embarrassed too I love my cringe Oshi A
murder case now Yeah For that, for the very reason that it
is such an important night.
Toes, toes!
Let's see, what else can I do?
Align, speaker.
Oh, let's lower the screen.
Let's watch the tape.
After all?
Oh, they don't seem to care at all, actually.
The junkyard where I died had a security camera, and it
captured the moment of my death perfectly.
And what the tape showed me was the cruelest truth
imaginable.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, we're moving!
We're alive!
It was...
I don't know.
Oh my god, that briefcase has been there the whole time.
Oh!
Did she actually?
I was wrong.
Yeah, that's pretty conclusive.
I would say so.
I saw myself shot right before my own eyes.
By Lynn.
There goes my only lead.
I feel like I've died all over again.
Unless, unless they were blanks.
Right?
They must have been blanks.
And then when I died for real, she was like, oh my god.
What?
one thing sticks with me though Lynn looks so surprised on
that tape what in the world did I tell
her um the truth is the truth no matter how many times you
watch it Inspector Cabanela
it wasn't me who played the tape just now baby
oh by the way okay we're just gonna ignore that fact by the
way Inspector Cabanela on that tape that troubles me what is
that chief of all ears I had to look at all the photos of
the crime scene as well but the place where the victim was
shot and where the body was found is clearly different no
didn't we know that reason he got pushed down didn't he by
the by the bad guy yeah he got kicked and fell over.
So we knew that already.
Yeah, the Hitman in Black is the one who kicked me
downstairs.
But I changed his fate, so he should have been...
Oh!
I changed his fate, so he should have been out of the
picture.
That's right!
But there I am, down on the lower level.
Hmm.
It's hard to remember what happened before and you know have
your the answer to your mystery right here a few minutes
after the murder took place oh okay nice oh my god security
cameras that actually work this is insane do I just fall
over cuz oh why was there a cat in my briefcase ow what is
what is that a black cat You got it, baby.
A furry feline messed up our crime scene.
And then the little cat Cobra vanished into the night.
Looks like my destiny of being knocked downstairs is very
hard to alter.
Uh-oh.
This is point X.
Come in, Chief.
Oh, my God.
The Chief here.
Did he show up?
No, sir.
Not yet, but...
Idiots.
I told you to stay off the radio unless it was over.
important but but this is important sir somebody else showed
up our rookie detective Lynn right row you see my baby over
there do you I heard she was on the lamb what do you want me
to do chief what do you say inspector there's no time for
dancing detective get my baby away from point X oh the
launch codes maybe the I think we know where they're
touching down do it now man and then hold on to her yes sir
I'll get her right now sir what is the meaning of this why
would lynch you up at point X
It took the Special Investigation Unit six months to
pinpoint that location.
Don't know, Chief, but I'd say it wasn't a coincidence.
Perhaps it was a ghost trick.
Oh, what?
Uh-oh.
Now what?
What happened this time?
Damn it.
Why did his feet do that?
This calls for a telephone call to point X.
Allow me.
Oh, yeah, you're allowed.
Trick time, baby.
No time to waste.
Maybe just a little bit time.
Why is he doing that with his feet?
Just a little bit of time to waste.
And then we lower it.
then we then we go telephone it what are you doing get your
buns over here oh shit is that her on the ground what did
you say now I finally understand I finally know what it's
like to murder oh for our poor hungry customers who have
their food deliveries delayed excuse me I think he needs to
go to a doctor for that what is going on with your nose but
this is the chicken kitchen is it not what aren't i talking
to the police the police did something happen there you need
assistance with something happened here you ask more like
there's nothing left here i gotta go what wait someone is
This itchy-footed man.
Why?
You're so nasty.
What is that?
What's that?
It's called?
Athletes' foot or something?
I'm getting my fork.
Off the ground.
My fork.
Okay.
going on something that's what something is definitely going
on and that something is far from nothing that's for a
certain so poetic thanks for the tea chief i'll be on my way
oh you're going to point x point x a i'll leave that to the
boys there's someplace else i gotta be inspector
Mint, if your feet are ever itchy, I'm here for you, Queen.
Your being there isn't going to change anything.
Why put yourself through it?
I have a responsibility, and I'm going to see it through to
the end.
Okay, maybe he's not a bad guy.
I can't tell, actually.
Besides, it's not quite over yet.
true do what you must oh god oh they're so jittery
prisoner d99's schedule for tomorrow was blank seems like
forever ago that i found that out now my mind is even
blanker than that blackboard was lynn my only lead and my
partner shot me what did it all mean i knew where i had to
go to get my answers the chicken kitchen the point X the
police have surrounded and the place where something big
just happened what will Lin be involved be involved in this
time when I find her there I kind of want to see does he go
to the jail yeah oh I didn't even realize there was stairs
over there we just didn't look I didn't even realize there
were stairs down there well I tried to move but it just
wouldn't let me it's stuck i was stuck in the jail new song
save the data nice all right let's keep going wait how long
have i okay almost four hours chapter seven oh we're almost
how wait it's what 19 chapters 18 19 i just can't get the
images i saw police headquarters out of my head the person
who shot me tonight it's the last person in the world i want
to believe did it 18 okay we're almost halfway there now i'm
here at the place she and i agreed to meet the restaurant
the police were staking out as point x when i got there i
found the place in ruins maybe another two to three more
streams yeah that's what i'm thinking unless i uh whoa
unless i like endurance the last part or the next part what
in the world happen here?
Big chicken.
Oh my god, she's dead.
She's dead.
Oh, the heavens.
What do I do if I had known something like this would
happen?
He's so smiley about it, though.
I would have paid the poor child more.
I would have cooked more chicken for her.
I would have sung to her as much as she liked until she had
her fill.
Actually, about the singing.
She did tell me she'd had a The chef seems to be in quite a
panic Oh, she's dead She's so cute You're too cute to die At
least it doesn't look like the waitress is dead Oh, just
kidding But this guy is That guy sure seems to be dead We're
just gonna roll down here
According to that police radio conversation I heard Lynn
should be here But I don't see her anywhere.
Seems like bad luck is in it for that redhead.
So I was half expecting to see her in trouble again.
Oh my gosh, I'm sorry.
I have an itch underneath the thing I put, the hot patch I
put on my shoulders.
But I can't get to it because it's...
Ow!
I'm good.
I spotted the corpse of the van driver.
That poor guy.
Oh, wait!
She's there!
Oh my god!
Why?
She was there!
Look at me, I'm dead!
What took you so long?
Huh?
Well, that's one way to greet a guy.
What happened here?
How should I know?
I'm the victim!
Is it just my imagination?
Or is she getting more and more brazen every time she dies?
Well, that's because I'm a detective.
I have to be tough, you know.
how did it go?
Did you check out tomorrow's work schedule for Prisoner
D-99?
Uh-oh.
Yeah, just like I promised.
Actually, I have a few things I want to ask.
I want to ask you about, too.
Sure.
We agree to use each other after all, right?
The troublesome GF experience?
Oh, no British accent?
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Let's swap info then.
Let's save my murderer for right let's start with point look
we'll go we'll work our way up point X the police were
staking this restaurant out tonight they called it point X
point X huh that's a good name for this place that white
suited inspector was a surprise to find out you just
casually waltzed in here inspector Cabanela what in the
world made you pick this place anyway I guess I'd have to
say if you Because of you.
Me?
What did I do?
Every time she dies, she gets a new accent.
She dies as much as Maya gets arrested in Ace Attorney.
So true.
Oh!
Do you remember that note I found?
The note I didn't get a chance to read.
I had a place and a time written on it.
The Chicken Kitchen 10 p.m.
In other words, I was supposed to meet someone.
Somebody here tonight.
Yep, apparently so.
I just had to get that information you were going to give
me.
Or I just had to get that information you were going to give
That's why I came here.
It was the only lead I had left.
Ah.
So this here is point X.
That must mean the mark the police were waiting for was me.
I feel like the music is a little too late.
light-hearted for what's going on.
Feels like you said, each prisoner had a little blackboard
in his cell.
But the thing is, there wasn't anything written on Prisoner
D-99's blackboard.
It was blank.
What?
I guess maybe it means his schedule for tomorrow hasn't been
decided yet?
Blank?
Huh?
I didn't think she'd lose it over a blank blackboard.
How come you're so upset about an undecided work schedule?
Oh, man.
I get the feeling that back when I was alive, I never had
much of a schedule to worry about myself.
Do you know what it means when a prisoner doesn't have a
schedule for the next day?
It means something?
Oh, gosh.
Cecil, please.
It doesn't mean he doesn't have work to do.
It's more like he can't work.
Because he's dead!
He's going to be executed!
Aha.
Executed?
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Execution.
Do you know what prisoner D99's crime was?
I think so.
They said something about him murdering his wife right in
front of a family member.
Her.
That's what they say, but it's not true.
He would never.
Detective Jowd would never do anything like that.
The death penalty hasn't been enforced in this country and
for a very long time, they're trying to get rid of him
because he knows something.
Not for decades.
Even if the prisoner wants it, like in this case.
The prisoner wants it.
There's definitely something else going on with this case.
I just know it.
And I have to find out what?
And if his work schedule is blank for tomorrow, I have to do
it right now!
So this prisoner D-99, Detective Jowd, he must be connected
to me in some way too.
not going to mention that like he had me drawn on his little
yeah look at that it's beautiful captures my best side and
everything after all he obviously knows me at last my
murderer on my way here I stopped by the chief of police his
office do you think he has a skip oh it was just on your way
was it and while While I was there, I saw who did it.
I saw my murderer.
You saw him?
Where?
How?
Not him.
Her.
There was a security camera set up there at the junkyard
where I got shot.
The security tape showed me the person who shot me.
It was a you.
And it was not AI generated.
Oh!
Flashback.
Were we possessed by the lamp?
Was she possessed by the lamp, maybe?
No way.
You're kidding, right?
What do you have to say for yourself, detective?
It wasn't me!
I didn't shoot you!
If I recall, this is what you said about who shot me.
My memory just isn't clear on that part.
So how can you say for sure that it wasn't you?
Because I told you before!
You were supposed to give me some information!
The lamp?
yeah the lamp information huh maybe that information was the
reason you shot me what what do you mean but why she shot me
what's the chat summary you
said you had some information on the case I'm looking into
so I would hardly shoot you before I even heard that
information right I agree that wouldn't make sense if it was
before huh but what if it was after you already gotten the
information from me bum bum bum bum bum oh she looks shocked
I definitely told you something then I killed you the lady
she's like no you know and whatever it It was.
It really shocked you.
What did I tell you?
I don't remember.
I don't know.
You've got to believe me.
After you saved me, I thought I got all of my memories back.
But maybe I really didn't.
I killed Bufasa.
I am your father, Luke.
You told me something.
I can't remember that part at all.
Because we were possessed.
You got the information you wanted from me.
And then you shot me.
Isn't that what happened?
No, no, I didn't shoot you!
Please tell me.
What did you tell me that time?
How am I- You know I have no memories.
I don't even know how to read, Lynn.
I can't even read.
What did I learn from you?
So, what are you going to do now?
I mean, you fulfilled your goal, right?
You found out who shot you.
Are you going to get revenge?
would be easy enough to do all you have to do is not save me
oh it's kind of a dilemma huh if I don't save her um you
know I end the I end the game to end this stream is this the
ending I was hoping for had I unraveled all of the mysteries
of me gosh I can see why so many people say this is their
favorite game ever it just ends like that.
That's it.
That's the story.
What am I going to do now?
I'm going to save you, that's what.
You are?
I want to know everything.
Who I was, why I was killed.
Yeah, I'd like to know who those guys are too.
The little blue guys and the grapes.
I want answers and I'm gonna find them.
But to do that, I'm gonna need your help.
Okay.
I won't say thank you.
Not yet.
And I won't say I'm sorry either.
But I'll help see to it that you get your answers.
Good.
Now I think it's time to go back to the past.
I can't leave you lying flattened under a huge chunk of
chicken forever after all.
Hmm.
Ooh.
Oh, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Alrighty, guys.
Let's solve this chicken dinner.
Let's cook this roast.
I mean, let's prep this roast.
The note says the chicken kitchen at 10 p.m.
I wonder who that pointy-haired man was going to meet here.
You know my name.
You know I'm Cicel.
What's this?
Today's special.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
She's so...
Whoa, I thought...
Oh my gosh, I thought that was like a...
alien lady for a second.
Bing bong.
I don't think she fits the vibe of this restaurant.
I love it though.
Can, yeah, can someone convince Kiara to get a skater outfit
like that next?
Can someone please convince her?
We need like a... Can I eat that thing?
Oh my gosh, Lynn, please.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Oh.
No.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Phew.
Lynn's got moves.
Yeah, she do.
You're just going bigger and better with each new death,
aren't you?
Leave me alone.
Can I help it if I got tired of dying the usual ways?
You could have just moved, Lynn.
You could have just moved.
But I'll say this.
It was a death any detective could be proud of.
Huh?
What makes you say that?
Because you saved her, you saved the girl, the way you saved
someone else before dying yourself.
Oh, that waitress?
The one with the chicken on her head?
The next time you put a chicken on your head, you should try
one about the size of the waitresses.
I'll make a note of that for next time.
But anyway, if you hadn't tried to save that waitress, you'd
still be alive.
No, no.
We're not choosing lives here.
I couldn't help it.
the detective thing and all i wasn't able to save that poor
van driver though i don't think there's no helping that guy
at the speed he must have died instantly well we can't let a
heroic detective like you stay dead the root of this whole
disaster is clear chicken the question is how do i stop it
okay let's get started hmm
Trick time Okay Menu board Sign Let's ring the bell Trick
Hello ma'am Oh my god she's so cute She's so cute You rang
Huh?
Oh sorry I didn't ring the bell.
Oh, okay, I get it.
This was a little dig, wasn't it?
Kind of like, hey, where's my food, right?
No, not at all.
Besides, I didn't ring it.
Oh, okay.
That's all right, then.
But the chef is the one who makes the chicken.
No sense in harassing me about it, right?
Dang.
Just keep that in mind, okay?
Bye.
Odd, girl.
I agree.
Me too.
What's wrong with her?
She didn't do anything.
What's this?
It's no use.
I can't read what it says.
Oh, let's see.
Now I remember what the sign says.
If you would like some water, please ring the bell.
Oh, three times.
Okay.
The waitress doesn't bring any water if you only ring the
bell once.
She said, those are the rules, apparently.
I said, apparently?
What do you mean, apparently?
Don't you work here?
Quite a stickler for the details, this detective.
Okay.
So let's...
You wrote this note, right?
I think so, but I don't remember.
10 o'clock.
That means it's already time for your meeting with whoever
it is.
Now that I think about it, whoever you were supposed to meet
might already be here.
You think the detective...
You're the detective.
Well, I can't read it anymore.
Shouldn't you have checked out when you got here?
Sorry, the chicken at this restaurant is really good.
you know um no i don't know take a look around the rest of
the restaurant
okay we're zooming around wow that's fancy but there's these
guys time is passing uh and then her aren't you gonna
deliver my food the chicken is just sitting there What are
you doing with that?
Okay, we hit it three times.
Give me my water.
Thank you, ma'am.
You want more water?
Um, I stay hydrated?
What's your issue?
Sorry, I didn't ring the bell.
And what's with the more water bit?
Oh, well, come on.
This is your third glass.
Okay, I get it.
This was a little dig, wasn't it?
Kind of like, oh, where's my food?
I would like to see you bringing me my chicken soon.
Dually noticed.
In the meantime, enjoy a nice glass of water.
Dang.
Thank you.
Odd girl.
I agree.
Okay.
Uh, what do they say?
What's taking my chicken so long?
Unfortunately for you, according to what we saw before, the
van arrives before your chicken's done.
In any case, just hanging around here isn't going to fix
anything.
I'll have to look for a way to get beyond this area.
Oh, when she comes over, I have to...
One, two, three.
Sorry, I'm bullying her a little bit.
I'm harassing the...
There we go.
Thank you.
Alrighty.
Nice Trick time To the cart And there it is I was like Are
we going to go up?
Time is passing Do you think this girl likes her job?
I think if I could rollerblade everywhere I would be very
excited about that Oh wait what did he say?
Here you go That's a big trunk this is one big trunk seems
pretty heavy too it's very suspicious and red my body is in
there let's see what's in it sorry but that's not possible
it's locked darn I wanted to see what was inside okay now we
can eavesdrop on these guys so what do you think my dear
beauty do you really think We can trust this deal.
Who knows?
It's not our job to think about that.
But those incidents did happen in this country, just as he
predicted.
Yes, and they were pretty amusing too, weren't they?
That fellow who sang out national secrets during live TV
broadcast?
And the man who laid siege to the Metro Police Department,
taking the top dog hostage.
If he had double crosses us, it wouldn't be pretty.
No, no.
He needs this deal, too.
And we've accepted all his conditions as well.
Yes, and thanks to that, we have to be here on this extra
little assignment.
But as long as I'm paired up with you, Beauty, I don't mind.
How do these two...
at the special prison yeah that guy's voice is so I know
right great voice acting thank you special prison the guy
who sang national secrets the man who held siege to Metro
police those cases are classified information well wouldn't
everyone know about the secrets because it happened at a
concert like hmm
I've heard about both of those cases, and recently, too.
The perpetrators in those cases are being held at a special
facility.
That's what the special prison is.
But it's not known about it by the general public.
So, prisoner D-99, Detective Jowd is one of these special
cases, too, huh?
Oh, it's a cover-up.
They erased the concertgoer's memories?
They have the power to do that!
They silenced the crowd.
With a gun?
These two are talking about the very same cases I heard
about just tonight.
How convenient.
Also, this guy's, like, margarita glass head is crazy.
That couldn't be just a coincidence, could it?
Is that a whip she's holding?
Or is that a...
That's not a cane.
Hmm.
What is that beauty?
Why don't we move to a different spot?
Waiter?
All the way over there.
That table in the back looks good.
Oh, now you're talking, beauty, my dear.
Just what I've been waiting for.
A quiet, secluded spot.
Just the two of us.
I wouldn't object to that.
I get this feeling somebody is eavesdropping.
My sixth sense is very strong, you know.
Oh!
Oh my god, she's noticing me?
Okay, beauty.
That's all right, my dear.
You don't have to make excuses.
Off we go across the bridge of poultry to the land of love.
Wait.
Take the chicken!
No, no, no!
Oh, I'm just...
No!
Oh, we get to watch them.
Oh, God!
God!
Stop with the Superchat.
What does that mean?
What just happened?
Did she sense we were here?
What?
With her sixth sense?
But, you know, I have some pretty amazing powers myself.
Yeah?
I'm like, what?
Like...
Like if there's...
There's chicken nearby.
I can tell right away.
That's called a sense of smell.
But anyway, at least the situation has changed a little bit
now.
Fate changed.
Uh...
I don't believe in a sixth sense.
It's not scientific.
Says the ghost.
Come to think of it.
We've been left behind, haven't we?
Yeah, we're kind of stuck here.
It looks that way.
Not having legs is even more inconvenient.
than I thought it would be.
What are we going to do now?
They're all the way over there.
I'm telling you, we'd better shake a leg.
We're going to miss what they're saying.
It'd be pretty hard to shake a leg.
Not having legs and all.
Meow.
Oh my god, he's blowing kisses at her.
They're still talking about something.
I want to hear!
Me too.
Alright, let's figure what.
Oh, what are we doing here?
a drink right can we we tried examining this and okay yeah
we it's still the same thing what is what if we dispense a
bottle oh oh oh oh oh oh
okay she
only comes for one bell here.
Wait, we make them a drink and she delivers it.
We make them a drink and she delivers it.
You're right.
Oh, I get it.
You saw that couple over there and you started to get
lonely, right?
And so you decided to call me.
Oh, that's so sweet.
Forgive me.
But I didn't ring for anybody.
What?
No, could you not stand in my light, please?
I can't see my glasses.
properly i've been working here for two days and i've been
waiting this whole time for you to notice me now would you
stop trying to shake me up and just stick to shaking
cocktails
okay no she's heartbroken with her unrequited love she has a
surprisingly short career with this place
okay she's back already oh so fast okay trick time Make them
a drink.
Oh, it just overflows!
Oh, I thought I could...
Okay.
I didn't realize it was going to be a cutscene.
I thought I would be able to ghost trick it to stop it.
You just broke that glass.
Just like you did my heart.
A broken glass can never be put back the way it was.
Just leave it there.
You can't just leave it.
Somebody might get hurt!
Doesn't this trunk belong to that couple over there?
The only things we're allowed customers to lose here are
their cares.
Miss, please go and let them know about the trunk, if you
would be so kind.
How gallant of you.
I just might fall for you, you know.
Yippee!
We got it.
Okay.
Oh, odd girl.
I agree.
Wait, we have to wait for him to put the glass down, maybe.
Oh.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, not yet.
Not yet.
Almost.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry for going back and forth so many times.
Well, goodbye.
I've been working here for two days and I've had my eye on
you the whole time.
I think this might be my last night working here though.
What?
It's been fun.
Wait, you just got here.
I guess she's leaving this place with her surprisingly short
career intact.
Oh, here he comes.
Of all things to forget, it wouldn't have been pretty if I
forgot this.
You know who I'm trying to channel is Thunderburger from
Over the Garden Wall.
I think that's who I'm trying to channel.
All right.
Here we are, finally.
Not Shaggy?
Like Scooby-Doo Shaggy?
No, he's like, Oh, Zoex!
Like Scoob.
He's got, like, a totally different voice.
I thought it was Shaggy.
Not at all.
I feel kind of bad about eavesdropping, though.
I don't.
Not me.
Yeah.
I'm on Lin's side.
I mean, we just delivered their lost trunk to them after
all.
They owe us at least that much.
What kind of detective says something like that?
fate changed so can we listen in on them now oh we can be
flowers oh we can whoa I'll swing a little bit oh my god
whoa I can't believe I forgot the trunk of all things now
I'm hearing shaggy with such a small body you probably only
match.
Ouch, that hurts beauty.
Oh no, I can't do, now I'm doing scoby.
I mean shaggy.
But like, that's okay.
That's what I love about you.
That's what he loves about her.
Oh my gosh, Lynn.
Don't kink shame.
I don't get it either.
Now where were we?
Oh, right.
Oh, to invite to the wedding.
that is of course with him she's like I'm glad there's
nobody around to listen to this we can talk about that when
we're alone but aren't we alone now beauty do you think she
senses our presence again I spy a ladybug oh ladybug I just
hate little bugs me too what What?
What?
Uh-oh.
Death is imminent, I suppose.
Death is...
After all that trouble, it happened anyway!
It looks that way, yes.
It's not over yet, though.
It's not?
What are you talking about?
You're not dead yet.
No.
I'm just...
I'm going to be in just a few seconds.
but before that happens maybe there's something we can do
from here trick time okay swing oh so close oh so close ah
there we go chicken bone oh my god wait wait wait wait whoa
oh my god
I'm trying to get to the...
Ah!
There we go!
The bold body inspection!
Hello?
It looks like he's unconscious.
Excuse me.
Could you wake up for a second, please?
Pushy as ever, this detective.
One thing I've learned is that the most newly dead stay
unconscious for a little while at first.
Huh?
I was like that.
And you were like that, too.
Yeah, I guess you're right.
Anyway, if we restart the flow of time now, you'll die.
Yeah, I know.
Why don't we try going back even further in time?
Even further, but how?
Simple.
We go back four minutes before the death of this poor driver
here.
You can do that?
I guess?
Yeah!
I never tried it before.
So I don't know how it'll go.
But if we can erase the driver's death, that should erase
your death too.
Oh, wow.
I can't think of any other way.
Let's try it.
Rewind.
Oh
my god, it's this guy!
What the?
Yes, I remember!
Oh my gosh, the park!
That's Lynn, our rookie detective.
Is he the guy that phones the police station?
What's she doing at point X?
Could it be just a coincidence?
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Yeah, Parkman and Hippie Man!
Yeah!
Um, what was I gonna say, though?
I don't remember.
And we just got an APB on her a little while ago.
Something about an extremely important case is extremely
important.
witness currently extremely on the run.
Now what?
Should I report this to Inspector Calp?
Yes, yes, yes, he talks to him.
So he's the one that
signals him.
Aha!
Time to catch some sleep minto.
Enjoy the rest of the stream.
Thank you!
Good night!
They told us to stay off the radio unless it was an
emergency.
But I think I'd better call this in.
Poor Lynn.
I wonder what she did this time.
What do you mean me?
Spectre Cabanella is pretty protective when it comes to Lin.
He'd want to know.
I'm gonna finish up this case and then we'll end though.
So once we save this guy.
What's the matter?
Alright.
Fine.
Who called?
And then we call people.
This is point X.
Idiot!
Oh, no, it's important!
Yes, sir.
Oh, go get her.
Okay.
I'm glad we got the cliff notes version of it.
Wee woo, wee woo!
The static is awful.
Um, eyes on the road, buddy.
Can't believe I forgot the trunk of all things.
Oh!
Such a small body, you probably only...
have a small bro he was listening he was listening in oh
that's what i love about you it was bugged i spy a ladybug
thank you for the don't know jason thunderburger that guy's
the total package
a ladybug i just hate little bugs it was bugged oh i can't
hear very well oh
so oh when she lit it on fire
dang i can't believe he crashed this is why you wear your
seat belts first of all i can't believe he crashed so
crazily that even though the steering wheel broke off rip
his eardrums this is this is you listening to be that's you
when you listen to vtuber stream sometimes isn't it you you
hear the scream and you're just like i'm being sent to
heaven the van driver looks like it looks like it i noticed
something though that conversation he was listening to just
before the crash i remember I remember hearing it before.
You're right, we heard it just a few minutes ago, didn't we?
One of your karaoke streams.
What do you mean by that?
I don't scream during my karaoke streams.
Are you saying that your ears are not blessed during my
karaoke?
Are you saying that I'm a shit singer?
Fine.
Everybody, you can thank Nine Breaker for me never doing
another karaoke stream ever again.
I'll never ever again get one guide just after that
conversation the detective suddenly passed out what happened
I wonder oh I know what happened we already know the answer
we saw what happened at the restaurant Yeah, she lit the
little bug on fire.
She burned up the ladybug.
Sometimes when a high-tech bug like that is destroyed, it
emits a loud signal.
I regret nothing.
I respect it.
He's like, if I go down, I'm going down with dignity.
You know what?
Stick to your ideals.
if that's what you believe then you know what don't just
don't just change your ideas because everybody else doesn't
agree with you that's your opinion he accomplished his
mission I I respect it stand proud
he's still getting lynched though no no i'm not wrong the
world is he basically said malice
uh so funny um find something to believe in right and even
if it's even if it's mince terrible
loud enough to knock a person out if they were listening to
it through headphones so that's why the detective passed out
huh bingo now let's stop it from happening
trick time oh oh i was like why was his soul there this is
the place that the white suited in your phone tonight.
This is a parking lot of the park on the east side of town.
It's been years.
You know this park?
Yeah, I used to play here a lot when I was little.
But then one day, I swore I'd never set foot in this park
ever again.
Because her father killed her mom.
Whoa, those are some really deep, dark feelings there.
I wonder what happened.
Hold it!
Don't give me that.
A ghost doesn't have a foot to set bit it's just a figure of
speech what kind of nitpicker do you think i am anyway
whatever let's get started okay let's do that i won't press
her about that other thing right now let's see we can go to
his flashlight we could go to a seat lover oh yeah let's put
that down
oh i guess we can uh flashlight we will we will Doesn't look
like the detective is going to come.
Thank God.
Might as well turn it off.
It's pretty loud.
Hold it.
What else can we get to?
Time is passing.
Oh, here he comes.
Here he comes.
And he's going to throw his binoculars.
And we can probably...
Yep.
Go to the binoculars.
They told us to stay off the radio unless it was an
emergency.
But I think I'd better call this in.
Poor Lynn.
I wonder what she did this time.
What does he mean this time?
Mind your own business.
I like to do things my way, okay?
Did she accidentally kill her dad?
Or her mom?
And that's why the guy...
in prison is wanting to take the fall
you know like what if she was a kid and she was just messing
around kind of like you know she was just messing around
with her like dad's her dad's a detective she just kind of
she's like I want to be like daddy too and she was playing
with the gun and it accidentally went off and killed her mom
and so that's why the dad was just like Oh my gosh.
I have to do the death penalty.
Because I can't let my daughter take the fall.
She was just a kid.
That's my current theory.
You got a cart before the horse.
Hmm.
That's...
Inspector Cabanela is pretty protective when it comes to
Lynn.
He'd want to know.
And because, like, because they're close, you know, like,
he's just like, he probably does not want her to become a
detective.
The Inspector Cabanela guy, right?
Because he's just like, you could, same thing could happen
to you.
But there's also the, all the other guys, too.
Hmm, I don't know.
I'm still cooking.
Oh!
So why are we involved?
Good question.
I'm cooking as all.
This is why I don't cook, okay?
Who is the detective talking to?
Don't keep yelling at me about these little things.
But they might be talking about something ridiculously
important.
That's true, but still, it might be the person who really
shot you.
Now you're just throwing things out there.
But in any case, it looks like it's too late to get to the
phone now.
I think we missed her.
But I didn't have a chance.
It didn't let me when he walked by.
I'm worried about that detective memory.
Who's the hell?
Who's detective memory?
They call her the Lynn of the Special Investigation Unit.
Is that a bad thing?
Well, well.
Did you hear that?
At least it's better than me being called the memory of the
detective division.
At any rate, I'd better report to Inspector Cabanella before
I worry about that listening device.
Yeah, see, when he's walking around.
I missed my chance.
Should I restart?
But...
Point X.
Chief here, did he show up?
No sir, not yet.
Blah blah blah!
I told you to stay off the radio.
Okay, this is important.
It's Lynn.
My baby.
What do you want me to do?
Get my baby away from point X.
Do it now, man!
Okay.
Now here.
He's on the move.
There isn't much time left.
We have to stop him fast.
Otherwise, he's going to crash into the chicken kitchen.
This is like that game, isn't it?
GTA?
Oh, game of chicken!
Sorry, but what's a game of chicken?
Sorry.
I'd better choose my audience more carefully the next time I
tell a joke.
Never mind that.
We have to do something.
Okay, let's put a seat down.
And if we do...
Yeah, we still can't reach.
If we put the seat down...
He will...
Maybe the headphones will fly off.
Recline!
Wow!
What do you think you're doing?
I just thought I'd do...
I'd better do something.
Never mind.
Hurry up and put the seat back up.
I can't.
It's too heavy.
How weak is this car?
Why does the steering wheel come off every time?
All I can hope is...
Yep, this guy has strong ab muscles.
Uh, I don't think he dies.
Somehow sped his death up.
Oh, time's up.
Oops, that was my bad.
I get that you felt like you had to do something, but that?
Well, there really isn't much I can do once the van is
moving.
We should rethink this.
Any other path before that?
Okay, from the beginning.
From the top, everybody.
From the top.
I, okay, can you think...
My logic wasn't so bad though.
Right.
My logic was pretty sound, I'd say.
Oh, that opened.
That's so cute.
What the?
It opens a little thing.
So cute.
was it though yeah I think I think I was how do I get over
there oh maybe I make a lot of noise and when he's trying to
listen yeah there we go he's like turning that blasted thing
off
oh ah
do the binoculars get launched by the seat ah Oh!
Pew!
Oh!
Phew!
Uh.
Did I do the wrong order?
Wait, what do you mean?
Just reset?
Okay, okay, I'll reset.
Uh, yeah, because we're going to reset.
We want to hear the phone call.
So he's gonna...
Okay, let's see.
What the?
I'm confused.
What's the order that I'm supposed to do?
But not kill her before siren.
Okay.
Phew!
Oh, and then he picks them up.
And then he carries them to the thing.
Okay, I think I get it.
Wee woo, wee woo, wee
woo!
Oh.
Yeah!
What are these doing here?
Wait, let me, let me, let me, let me!
Please!
There we go.
Okay.
Now we follow them.
Okay, okay.
Good, good, good, good, good.
Okay.
What's the matter?
Here we go.
Honk.
Detective Ridge?
This is memory.
Oh, she's memory.
Things been super tight.
What's the matter?
It's not time for your regular report.
Did she just miss me?
Listen to this.
There's a suspicious couple in the bar upstairs.
I'm going to put a ladybug on them.
A ladybug?
You mean a listening device?
Don't do anything to blow our cover.
Inspector Cabanella will be furious.
But they are doing all kinds of suspicious whispering.
We have to find out what they're saying.
You can pick up on the signal from your van.
Check out their conversation for me, would you?
All right, fine.
Once you get going on something, I know there's no stopping
you.
Okay, so we have to figure out a way for her to change the
position of the bug.
Okay.
Later then.
She's the murderer.
Hold on.
Did you see a customer come in just now?
A young woman with red hair and red boots?
Oh yeah, that restless, suspicious chick?
Sure.
Suspicious.
I mean, come on.
As soon as she sat down, she ordered three glasses of water
in a row.
And she spilled the second glass on the table.
Okay, fine.
Keep your eye on her, too, if you're...
would you got it oh wow that waitress was an undercover
agent and she apparently thought you were pretty suspicious
too oh yeah sorry I was really thirsty so you know no I
don't know anyway did you hear about what I heard about the
listening device we have to do something about that bug so
we have to stay here or follow up on the waitress looks like
it's time to make a decision
Go there!
Can't even be a dojiko without being called suspicious these
days.
Alright, SMH.
Okay, trace complete.
We're in the kitchen.
We're cooking for re- Whoa.
He just cooked the whole thing on a frying pan.
Look where we are!
The heart of the chicken kitchen.
I keep wanting to say the kitchen chicken.
I keep wanting to mix them up.
Whereas most people say the kitchen.
I hope the key to preventing that incident is here
somewhere.
Oh, I bet it will be.
You know what they say.
Where there's smoking chicken, there's fire.
Now that you mention it, it is pretty smoky in here.
let's see what we got in here we got a little t-shirt
scrunch and stretch a switch that we can turn on that's the
phone what does this do scrunch oh my god so cute a pie and
the kettle
rock that kettle oh rock that kettle Never mind.
Do you think that's...
Oh, she's doing it right now!
She's probably planting the ladybug.
Now that I think about it, it's this waitress's meddling
that starts the whole chain of events.
The detective wouldn't have gotten his ears blown out and
wouldn't have crashed.
In other words, we're witnessing it with our own eyes.
The cause of a huge disaster slowly being planted in a
chicken.
Hey, I just had a good idea.
The outfit reminds me of something.
It reminds me of the waitress outfit that Maya wears as
an...
Where is an ace attorney?
About what to do about the ladybug?
We could get her crushed under the chicken instead of me!
No!
I can't tell if you're kidding.
At any rate, now we've seen the root cause of the incident.
to do now is think of a way to take care of it.
Lynn is literally suggesting murder right now.
What is in his hat?
I think that's wine.
I think that's a bottle.
Oh my god, you guys.
If you ever start seeing Mataro wearing a suspiciously large
hat.
It's Remy.
No, it's not Remy.
I can't tell.
What's this switch?
It's smoky in here.
What's wrong?
I can't seem to raise this switch.
It won't budge.
Not surprising considering this whole place is sticky with
grease.
I bet it must be stuck.
It does feel pretty sticky.
It's orange?
It's alive?
What if the switch...
Wait, really?
Wait.
But if the switch were already raised, I bet I could manage
to lower it.
Oh, you're right.
What is in there?
What's in the hat?
Maybe it's his head?
Maybe he's got...
Remember the other guy that...
Maybe they're related.
Him and the other guy that likes the curry and chicken.
Him and the curry and chicken guy are related.
Oh, she's raising it.
Oh, one bad.
there we go and lift
nice oh wow it was really smoking in there and turn it off
she's still trying to bug that thing oh see I told you it
was a bottle you guys all said it was a rat you all said it
was a rat
uh Can I use, can I, I don't think I can attach, uh, oh,
I think I need to be on his hat so I can get to the lower
stuff.
Oh, maybe.
There we go, there we go.
Operating this, oh!
Hey, what's up with this lazy Susan?
It's acting up today.
Maybe it's out of sorts because I was spinning around.
Oh, I know what we need to do.
I know what we need to do.
We need to make it smoky.
While she's working on setting up the...
lifting the thing, we gotta switch it so she doesn't realize
that we switch them.
I get it now.
I get it.
Okay, it's a matter of timing once again.
Oh, maybe it's out of sorts.
How about thinking maybe it might be broken?
But it really isn't broken.
It's just us ghosts.
Oh, we're stuck here though.
Uh-oh.
We're stuck here until we can get through.
Oh!
Uh-oh, I think I just did the timing bad.
Uh, alright.
So from here, um, we'll wait.
We'll wait in the hot.
Hopefully the timing...
Climbing works.
Hopefully it gets nice and stuffy.
It's smoky in here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yes!
Alright, now we wait.
There we go!
Okay, that should be it.
That should be it.
Oh, I should be a detective, shouldn't I?
There, I'll say it.
nice there
how about that the ladybug is still sitting on the table we
did it
chicken thou art so beautiful chicken a chicken you just I
took a bite my heart swelled with pride and I got goosebumps
What the heck is this?
I'm consumed with the love of consuming you.
Chicken,
chicken, chicken, chicken, chicken.
Well, it looks like you've escaped the fate of being
hammered by your horrible head.
but I still haven't escaped the worst darkness of this
terrible night.
I shot you, didn't I?
Don't sing too much, you might shock the poor driver's ears.
Oh my god, I'm now the cause of the incident.
There must have been some sort of complicated set of
circumstances that made you do it.
It's never okay to shoot a person, no matter what the
circumstances.
Hey, shouldn't be that... Shouldn't that be my fault?
line but anyway you were investigating a case and I was
supposed to give you information on that case maybe it's
time you told me about it tell me about the case you're
looking into whoa yes I guess I should let's go back to the
new present first okay sure okay back to the present I
thought there would be music so I could drink my water Back
in the new present, the delicious aroma of chicken fills the
air.
But I'm still thinking about Lynn.
I wonder if she's still waiting for her chicken to be
served.
I decided to go see her.
See her and ask her the questions that were still consuming
me.
Not concerning you.
Consuming.
Bam.
I'm still stuck here until this guy decides to...
Until this guy...
I'm still...
Oh, there we go.
Uh, why is there even a button down here?
Um, the chicken kitchen?
Beem, beem, beem, beem, beem.
Okay, very gooed.
Like, if this was a cheese restaurant, I would have said,
very gooed, uh.
The disastrous accident has been completely erased.
Once again, I've saved the red-headed detective from death.
The criminal who stole my life.
And you saved another man's life, too.
Let's not forget about that as well.
But also, what were those guys doing upstairs?
Boo!
I know you guys would like it.
Thank you.
You guys are too kind.
Oh my gosh.
One question in particular hangs heavy on my mind.
Why did she shoot me?
Till I know the answer, I'll never be satisfied.
Oh!
Wait, maybe she's actually related to the other guy.
Meanwhile, Lynn's appetite is apparently foremost in her
mind.
A golden brown chicken sits on the table in front of her.
Until she eats the whole thing, she'll probably never be
satisfied.
Wait, how do we get over there?
Telephone book, menu board.
She's not holding onto anything.
Oh, I didn't know you were here, Dick, to range.
Come to see me, didn't you?
Oh, that's so sweet.
Oh, hi, memory.
Uh, don't mind us.
Just pretend we're not here.
Why don't you try some chicken while you're here?
No, thanks.
Oh, the water.
That's right.
I gotta do the water thingy.
Just watching Lynn eat is quite enough for me.
So, how to turn out?
With my ladybug.
device?
Well, let's see.
I thought the gentleman had a very nice singing voice.
Sorry, but we're in the middle of an important talk.
Could you leave us to it?
But you guys are the ones who call me over.
Yeah, we need her to be holding the pitcher.
Odd girl.
I agree.
Me too.
She needs to be oh wait, that's right.
One, two, three.
There it is.
did you decide you want some chicken or me oh miss memory
she's she flirts with anything that breeds we didn't call
you sorry but could you give us some privacy no stay right
there huh I'm at the crucial moment with this chicken here
I'll need you to pour me some water if it starts going down
wrong.
Lynn, you don't have to risk your life over chicken, you
know.
Oh my God, we're gonna have to save her from the chicken.
He's right.
Look at her attacking that thing.
I definitely want her calm down there, Momo.
Calm down there, okay?
Anyway, I better move now while I have the chance.
Trick time.
Oh, that's funny.
Even though I just saved that detective, he doesn't have a
core.
Not like the one Lynn had.
Or that valiant little doggy missile.
Maybe because he was unconscious, we couldn't talk to him.
I thought the ones I saved are supposed to develop a core
when they're alive again.
Hmm.
I guess I still have things to learn about these powers of
the dead.
Man has no soul.
I'm heading back now.
Lots of things to do, you know.
Yeah, like washing dishes and planting bugs.
Someday I'll plant a big one on you, detective.
Whoa!
She's so forward.
Goodness, girl.
Odd girl.
I agree.
Me too.
Bing, Bing.
Listen, Lynn.
You've explained your side and I understand.
But there's an APB out on you.
Can't you at least hurry up and get out of here?
You know.
away quietly me three no can do i'm meeting somebody here
meeting somebody oh yeah that's right the little lady
camilla but why do you have to meet somebody here the
special investigation unit is watching this restaurant now
how can that be a coincidence i don't know but it is a
coincidence yeah where is camilla hey is it true what they
say that you're still looking into Detective Jowd's case on
your own.
Inspector Cabanella is worried about you, you know.
I understand how you feel, but just don't do anything crazy,
okay?
Odd girl.
What is that supposed to mean?
Um, huh?
Odd girl, pointing at me.
Time to invade her brain.
So how's that chicken you've been waiting so long for?
It's great!
Chicken puff cereal.
No, wait.
That's Rishi's puffs.
Chicken for breakfast?
No, chicken puff cereal!
They're great!
But you know, with Detective Ringe, that's his name, by the
way, sitting right across from me.
I mean, he was just dead a few moments ago, right?
That's kind of taking the edge off my appetite.
Oh, brother.
This guy stinks.
But he's a great guy.
He understands my situation, he said.
You're thinking of Frosties.
I'm mixing them both up, okay?
I'm mixing everything up, okay?
I knew it.
I already know.
You don't have to tell me.
He's going to give me a pass just for tonight.
Speaking of Detective Ringe, I noticed something strange.
He doesn't have a core now.
He doesn't?
I thought a core was supposed to show up once I saved
somebody.
Hmm, I wonder if when he possessed his corpse, he was
unconscious, right?
Unconscious, yeah.
He was, wasn't he?
Just like you, you were unconscious the first time I saved
you, too.
After I saved you, you didn't have a core either.
So for people who are...
See?
I already called it.
For people who are unconscious, when you save them, no core
shows up i think that's probably what it is we had to save
her a second time before she regained her memory or regained
any sentience you might be right okay i'll leave range to
you then but i've still got lots of questions for you yeah i
thought you would she's just sitting here eating and like in
her thoughts talking with this ghost and the other
detective's like lynn lynn lynn lynn i know you really love
the chicken but you just gotta answer me, Lynn.
Lynn, just say anything, Lynn!
Let's get started then.
Oh, okay, right now?
Okay.
Let's start with bottom up again.
Bottoms up?
Sure it's taking Camilla long enough.
She should have been here by now.
I'm getting really worried.
Me too.
You two are like sisters, aren't you?
That's what Camilla said.
Yep.
That just about sums it up.
It doesn't look like being... It doesn't look like being
worried affected your appetite much though hey the bigger
the crisis the more a girl's gotta eat so true i have to
make sure camilla stays safe no matter what camilla and that
music box the music box oh my gosh we got that last time
it's been so long since we've heard about it oh yeah that
wooden box that one yeah That box was a present from
Detective Jowd.
Oh.
From Detective Jowd.
Yes, it was five years ago.
That box arrived three days after that murder incident.
Sorry, I was just cooking in my brain.
He must have sent it just before he was arrested.
I was like, what if once the detective went to jail, he
like, gave her away to another family and that's why her and
Camila are like sisters and like what if what if um Cicil
was the the father figure but she also didn't know who he
was so I guess that doesn't make sense hmm he must have sent
it just before he was arrested someday when the case is over
and everything is settled I want you to give this to a
certain person he said Ooh.
So what's inside?
Oh, no.
Was I the person?
Was Sizzle the person?
I don't know.
I can't open it.
Hmm.
That's a shame.
Yeah, she would have recognized him then.
Hmm.
She wouldn't have been that young.
It was only five years ago.
Oh.
I thought it happened.
I thought it happened a long time ago.
Oh, well.
Detective Ringe works for the Special Investigation Unit.
down here tonight at this restaurant a deal okay then what
if Camilla's the one that shot the guy that's Camilla's dad
instead the deal that could affect the future of our nation
a nation isn't something that's easily influenced though but
that's what he said anyway it's that couple at the table
upstairs oh yeah I heard they're foreigners the wait they're
waiting for the other party in this deal to show up now
those two huh they certainly are an odd pair
is this other party they're waiting for watashi mmm to the
blue people country they're all just smurfs you guys they're
just big smurfs don't you know that like because there's so
much pollution that has happened the smurfs have mutated
into full-sized people.
Too
much raspberry slurpees country.
Are they still blue?
That's why they're blue.
They're just freakishly large smurfs now.
But average human size.
But freakish, really giant, large smurfs.
Every smurf with a giantest fetish is like, woohoo!
Yeah!
But every other Smurf is like, oh no!
Oh my god, this is ruining our lives.
We can't even go back home.
We just squish our families.
No!
That's what's happening.
It's kind of hard to imagine, isn't it?
The Smurfs, the Smurf population.
I'm sorry, my conversations nobody really knows any of the
details of the deal except for one person our favorite guy
mr.
breezy dancer in a white suit they say he's been watching
the movements he's been watching his movements of those two
for a long time I've never seen him work so frantically on
an investigation before Inspector Cabanella, eh?
Apparently, you're a real favorite of his.
The favorite?
Yes, well, there's a reason for that.
And what's that?
The reason?
Inspector Cabanella and Detective Jowd were good friends.
Yeah, I think I remember the prison guard saying something
about that.
Oh, my gosh!
Gumshoe!
Detective Division the very same day.
They're two very different types, but they were always in
friendly competition to be the best.
Oh!
A ba-ba-ba-ba!
Detective Jowd was always very particular about and thorough
investigation of the crime scene.
Yeah!
Oh, howie!
An inspector Cabanella, well, I guess he just has a natural
genius for investigating.
he's a cheater.
Other people do the work and he takes the credit.
those two led the detective division in those days.
Oh, but Inspector Cabanella is different now.
He changed a little.
He changed?
Ever since the detective Jowd incident, now he distances
himself from fieldwork.
And he's starting to focus on nothing but moving up the
ladder.
Well, maybe he's also trying to move...
I'm keep switching sides.
I'm like, he did it!
No, he's a good guy!
He's trying to...
He's framing him!
No, he's trying to find a way to get him out of jail!
Little A, but before I go to bed, I just want to say big
congrats on 200k!
Damn it, you're pretty good.
Thanks, Ghost of Me!
Ghost of Me?
Ghost of Ghost.
Good night!
Good night, good night.
now now I'm just like is he moving up the ladder because he
wants to be the top dog to not give that guy the death
penalty so that's how he became head of the special
investigation unit I take it anyway inspector Cabanela took
me under his wing because you were the little girl his good
friend had saved huh he really looked out for me helping me
study for my detective's exam fudging my exam school what
what do you what do you mean by that Lynn no no no no no no
Lynn Lynn Lynn you didn't you you put you passed we don't
have someone out here a detective out here who who is she's
perfectly capable everybody Lynn Nepo baby uh that goes a
little beyond the scope of looking out for you inspector
cabinella a i wonder what role he played plays in everything
that's happening tonight okay okay
i wasn't expecting nepotism what is going on all right death
row inmate joward to prisoner D-99, Detective Jowd.
He seems like more than just a co-worker.
Yes, I suppose you have the right to know.
Detective Jowd is my hero.
Hero, huh?
You don't hear that word much anymore?
She's cute so loud.
It's like finding out your doctor used chat GPT.
Oh, God, you're right.
It's like, oh, I just I just Googled it on WebMD, obviously.
It's an old-fashioned hero kind of story.
It happened 10 years ago.
Now just calm down and drop that weapon.
Stay back.
Have you got any closer?
I'll shoot her.
On that day, 10 years ago, I was playing in my favorite
park.
and then suddenly somebody grabbed my arm from behind I was
so scared I thought I was going to die and then
he appeared Detective Jowd
and then that really loud sound I think it was the sound of
a gun I passed out when I came to I Oh my gosh, he's a baby.
You're all right now.
Are you hurt?
You saved me, mister.
Oh my gosh, she woke up with a British accent.
I was just doing my job.
The gods, they're the ones who saved you.
What's your job, mister?
Me?
I'm a police detective.
What is that?
There was like, one of the, oh my gosh.
One of the...
I think it was like a movie recently the one with like
beatboxing puppy or whatever if you've heard of that like in
the beginning of the movie she has like a British accent and
then and then like as part of like the lore explanation she
was like when I when I when I grew up I lost my accent and
it was very clearly like they didn't want to pay another
another actor to do like a British accent when she wasn't
told or something.
Not the beatboxing puppy.
It's the same thing except opposite here.
She got scared so badly she developed a British accent.
That whole movie is literally AI.
I don't think it was though, wasn't it?
Like, apparently it was some YouTuber that had been, like,
creating it for a really long time and was, like, this is my
masterpiece movie!
But it was just not good movie.
Anyway, me?
I'm a police detective.
Okay.
So that's why he became a detective, huh?
That's right.
He was my ideal of what a detective was all about.
shoot and kill his own wife.
True.
Mm-mm.
That's why I didn't want...
That's why I went to prove that he didn't.
Cicel, I...
Did I really shoot you?
Oh my gosh.
She is just like her hero.
Where did that come from?
Out of the blue.
I really don't remember.
and tried but i just can't now i finally understand how you
must feel and how hard it is to have your memory gone your
story erased but who knows knowing the truth might be even
harder i'd rather believe there's hope myself
nice we should almost be done with this chapter though right
oh dang she ate the whole thing that was great do I have
chicken on my face you're staring I bet you're thinking
about how impressed you are with the way I took care of that
chicken just tell me one thing this case you say you're
looking into is it detective jowds
what if it was I can't keep it from you it's too cruel uh oh
no he's about to die before he tells us the information.
What are you talking about?
I'm sorry, Lynn.
It's tonight.
Oh, okay, okay.
Never mind.
His execution.
Detective Jowds, you know.
It's tonight.
His execution.
But there's still time.
I looked into it and I found out all the executions in this
country are carried out at dawn.
That may be the norm, but...
this time i'm afraid what the execution is set for 11 p.m oh
my gosh wasn't it nine what did you say it's going to happen
pretty soon oh isn't there anything we can do to stop it of
course not it's too late now not without a stay of execution
from the justice minister going to see him then what see who
who else the justice minister don't be ridiculous there's
not enough time I'm going sisal me get to the prison stop
that execution easy enough for you to say detective range
I'll be going now okay I'll let you go this time I'll tell
him I was distracted because I was eating chicken he's a
good guy he's a good guy is there anything else I can do
could you find Camila she's supposed to be on her way here
oh your little Camila okay you got it I'll look for her okay
you know what to do sisal you have to save detective Jowd
runs away
yet another person is connected to some I'm connected to is
somehow about to end tonight.
Could it be a coincidence?
Or is there something more behind it all?
Detective Jowd is destined to be executed tonight.
I don't know if that fate is the wrong one for him or the
right one.
But I've decided to go to the prison anyway.
Okay.
Wait, I'm sorry.
The 1005 to 1055 chat.
Okay, wait.
So it's supposed to happen in five minutes no way um this is
i'm glad that we just finished because my throat has been
killing me um i think it's a good point to end
wait oh sorry my bad i just realized i just turned off the
music i turned off the wrong thing ah there we go okay
You're leaving us?
Yeah, sorry.
This is so fun.
I hope you guys are enjoying the story so far.
What are we?
Chapter select.
Thank you.
So we're at chapter 8 out of 18.
So, gosh, there's still so much to go.
There's still so much to go.
I'm really invested in the story now.
Thanks for the stream.
I hope you have a restful sleep tonight.
Thank you.
Thanks to the stream, Ten-Side, cute, odd ghost detective.
Looking forward to more of this game.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, we're not even halfway, man.
That's crazy.
So probably two, three more streams.
I'm going to aim for two, though.
I'm going to aim for two.
I would like to finish it before I leave for...
I can finish it before I leave for Off-Kai.
For sure, for sure, for sure.
Yeah.
The rabbit hole is deep.
It is.
nice um but yeah for those who are watching the story for
the first time i hope you're liking it for those who um for
those who uh are um fans of the game or played it before i
hope you are liking my playthrough hopefully my brain is
expanding on at enough at enough rate for your for your um
to be satisfying thanks for the stream i love this game so
much Glad you're enjoying it.
Tomorrow I'll have an exam and I'm pretty nervous.
Wish me luck, Conqueror.
You are the Conqueror with the Von Karma, Francisco Von
Karma profile picture.
You've got this.
Hmm.
You're going at a pretty good pace.
It says guy who loves this game.
Cool, cool, cool.
I'm going to go get some more tea and I'm going to go to
sleep.
What am I doing tomorrow?
Uh, hold on.
Checking my schedule real quick.
uh
Shashingo which if you're not aware of what that game is
it's basically a game where you take pictures and learn
stuff in Japanese So we can learn Nihon go
Yeah, fake me.
Thanks for this super chat Mike Taishan.
Thank you for this super chat.
Hope you have a good night.
You too You too you too.
Yeah, so I was wondering if you've listened to Atarashi
Gakko.
I know they're not really the typical idol group, just
wondering.
I have, I have listened to them a little bit.
Thanks for the Superjack!
Congrats on 200k, thank you!
Actually, I, um...
Oh my gosh, I have pictures from an old...
Let me see.
I have to check how long ago this was.
Um, that I didn't realize it was...
Like, I had, I had gotten to the exhibit for something else,
but it was a collaboration with them as well.
It was like them and another brand.
Back in...
I'm looking through my pictures.
Oh, wait.
I posted the picture in 2016, but it said throwback.
I'm not sure when I posted the picture it says throwback so
actually I don't know at all when this it might have been
2016 that sounds right um but yeah so I've known about them
for a while but so it's really crazy to see that they but I
never listened to them back then I was never like a huge fan
but it's really crazy to see how popular they've become now
they're like everywhere Eight years ago.
Yeah, right?
Okay.
I'm going to go rest you guys as well.
I'll try to wear Ace Combat merch at Off-Kai.
I hope you will see you.
But if unable to meet you during meet and greet...
Or unable to see you, I will post my merch on Twitter
after...
Yeah!
Post it!
I will be at Off-Kai.
B.
Shojo is very kind enough to let me be in one of the little
robots as well.
Um, Matara and I will be going around in our robots and, um,
uh, if you don't get a meet and greet, um, if you can't go
to the con, uh, sorry.
But if we don't get a meet and greet at the, at the con, um,
we will be, we'll be also going around as well, so, um, they
sold out.
What the, the meet and greets?
The meet and greets?
Oh, the Khan sold out.
I was going to say, I don't think the meet and greets are
sold.
They're a lottery.
But also, if you can't make it to Off Kai, maybe another
time and place.
Hopefully.
We'll do our best.
Yeah.
Um.
But yeah.
Otsumito everybody!
Thank you so much for joining me again today.
And we will finish the game.
Uh, eventually.
Can you and Matara do like battle bots and fight each other?
I sure hope so.
I demand Mint to fly to our houses in drone form for all the
people who missed it.
Hey, I possess you guys sometimes.
Isn't that enough?
Okay.
it's late get a lot to rest you guys bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye
have a good night have a good night bye-bye bye-bye-bye see
you bye-bye oh oh oh oh oh I always forget to turn this off
okay bye bye bye-bye bye-bye Bye-bye.
Bye-bye.